okay so we'll be going live in three two
and one
look at lanika Agnew Stuart mcgiver
Louise Coleman Paul Thompson John
careford will be joining us later on and
Dave Pilcher from Orange County Council
has uh has joined us for help with any
Highway matters and to my immediate left
we have David Jeffries who is our
planning Manager David I believe you
have a statement to make thank you chair
yes my role is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you fabulous thank
you very much let's dive into the agenda
itself do we have any apologies for
absence please
yes chair we have two apologies uh from
Council next Kendall and councilor Parry
for whom comes to car give us
substituting welcome Council cargo
uh okay and any disclosures of interests
please members crank you there's a lot
we're going to start with Council Rock
first okay thank you uh clearly
interested on the award member for uh
item eight Rock Farm stud uh I should be
withdrawn from the committee for that
item marvelous thank you very much
Council Mills next thanks Mr chairman
um on the last application nine on the
agenda the cottage Isles cup bro I'm
actually the county councilor for this
um this award
um but I I posted as an open mind I'm
not spoken to any of anybody about this
particular so you'll remain yep perfect
cancer thank you I wasn't able to attend
the site visit for python 7 uh but I did
go myself and I have actually walked the
site okay marvelous thank you very much
councilor Adam please uh item number
seven thank you uh is I'm the
neighboring Ward member and I can't in
all honesty seven I'd be open-minded so
I shall leave the table at that point
okay understood cancer
zero zero two zero for full and I should
be withdrawing from the committee to
speak them understood thank you very
much councilor Harvey uh item six on the
agenda I have a conflict of interest I
shall withdraw and speak to it marvelous
anyone else
just me I am the war member on the first
application which is 2202 493 fulland
adjacent to herpes Farm in Clarendon I
will be withdrawing from the chair at
that point uh in order to be able to
speak and now I do need to find in the
absence of our vice chairman I do need
to find a uh a replacement chairman for
me so I'm going to propose councilor
Crump as our Chairman's take over
seconded by Council Mills I think thank
you very much councilman anyone else
want to put their name forward or put
someone else forward any other proposals
note in that case Council Crump will
take the chair in just a moment
um we do we have any meeting meeting
minutes uh as everyone happy with the
minutes as they're laid out in the
agenda I can see lots of nodding greed
hands up yep lovely okay I will sign
them later on okay in that case I'm
going to withdraw now um and hand over
to the very capable councilor Crump
all right thank you everybody
um one day we moved to item four and the
agenda which is uppercase in 22 slash
zero two four nine three slash
adjacent to Hercules Farm Henley Road
cleverden and our case officer is in it
and the book at Emma over to you please
thank you
[Music]
so order of proceedings
[Music]
um so today before members we have an
application for the erection of a new
dwelling
and all the associated Works
um your application site is outlined
here with the red line
this map also shows the boundary of the
clavidan conservation area and the
buildings in red are statutory listed
buildings so this one to the east of the
application site is Hercules Farm that's
grade two listed and that is where our
applicant currently resides
um so the application site forms part of
a large land agricultural holding
and this land is historically associated
with this list of building at Hercules
Farm
and in our office's report we've
explained how this land is considered to
contribute to the setting of that listed
building another thing to know is that
the application site falls into lands
that has been graded as medium
sensitivity for archaeological remains
which we've also discussed in the report
[Music]
ice cream
so this slide is um just the OS maps to
show you the wider conduct so we've got
visually clavidan to the to the east of
the application site
um you can see the Henley Road which
runs from east to west so the
application site is adjacent to that and
highly visible from that road
and from uh there you get impressive
views across the iron landscape across
to Preston baguette and Henley and Arden
so this um was just to show members the
site in the in the wider context so it's
rural in character at the edge of the
Village
um and you you can get an appreciation
of those landscape views that we talk
about in the report
[Music]
this um is useful for understanding the
extent of the Agricultural holding so
the blue line
um denotes the the land that's in the
same ownership as the applicant you can
see the the smaller parcel of land which
is our application site
so here again you can see the
application site with the red circle
you've got the village boundary
um with the in the bold black line and
you've also got the boundary of the
conservation area shown on there in pink
so from this we can establish that the
site is outside of the village boundary
line it's in the open Countryside it is
in the green belt and it's also adjacent
to the Conservation Area
so this slide is an extract taken from
the neighborhood plan in this section
they talk about valued Landscapes and
they have policies which seek to protect
those value Landscapes so again the
application site is shown with the in
the red circle so you can see that the
proposal would impact on those landscape
views that are B2 and B3
um and in the NDP it says that from
these Vantage points
um across the fields they're far ranging
or reaching views across the Henley and
Arden Preston Baggett Tamworth in Arden
Redditch and bombsgrove
so here we have the proposed site plan
and you can see um in the context of the
surrounding built form you can see
Hercules Farm there on the um on the
right hand side
oh yeah I should say as well that this
um particular plan is useful for
illustrating the changing land levels on
the site so you can see with the contour
lines the Henley Road is a higher land
level than the land on which the
dwelling is going to be built or
proposed to be built on and you've got a
difference of about a meter so it does
sink down
again the proposed site in more detail
so you can see that they are proposing
some hard standing for the driveway and
a brick boundary treatment
um yeah so masonry brick wall that is
mirrored on the other side that the
entrance to Hercules farm so that is the
future of the street
already
floor plans so you can get an
appreciation of open plan living at
ground floor and then with further
delivering accommodation on on first
floor there's three bedrooms
um one of the rooms is labeled an office
or a study so that could potentially be
an additional four bedroom so
[Music]
yep
so these are this is the design
um
you see yeah that's the design so you've
got low Eaves or different Eaves levels
quite a substantial roof these prominent
Gable features
balconies on all sides
um so the materials
we've got rendered elevations with a
concrete tile roof and upvc windows
so this um is a street or a section just
showing how that dwelling would be sunk
sunken down compared to the Henley Road
but the roofs would be still be very
visible
so now we've got our
site photos so
I'm standing on the Henny Road looking
into the site and we've got Hercules
Farm in the background
this is just turning looking East so
that's the entrance to the coverton
village and the conservation area there
looking the opposite direction to the
Henny Road taking you down towards
Henley and Arden in that direction the
site is where the the road traffic the
speed limit sign is
[Music]
so those landscape views that we talk
about in the report that's Illustrated
with the orange arrow the difference in
land levels from the road into the site
I'm stood in an existing access to the
site
um which was implemented as part of a
previous permission so they would be
utilizing the same the same access
again just more views across the
application site
and that's not that one cross towards
Henley and Arden the advantage point
and this is just to show members what
the current
um you know local architecture is in the
immediate context so we've got
rural character with traditional
detailing but a range of um
external facing materials
so in summary
we have recommended refusal on
foregrounds or for full reasons to
members the first of which relates to
the unsustainable location in the open
Countryside we've also identified that
the development is inappropriate
development in the green belt
um we've also identified or consider
that there is harm to the setting of
Hercules Farm the list of building and
the character of the Conservation Area
um
with the site being identified as having
medium sensitivity for archaeological
deposits there was an expectation that
we would get a an archaeological report
or survey submitted with the application
um that's not that's not been done so
that's an additional reason for refusal
we've also identified a conflict with
the neighborhood development plan and
our landscape policy in the course
strategy on the grounds that it's going
to be built in these protected landscape
view Vantage points
um and the final reason relates to the
design and scale of the dwelling the
fact that it conflicts with the design
guidance set out in the NDP
in essence we consider it harmful to
distinctive nurse and sense of place in
clavidon so
that's it
and an update sheet
oh yes in the update sheet you'll find
that we have a parish council and
objection
um
they were aware of the the
recommendation from refusal and agreed
with with those reasons and then just
emphasized that they considered its
conflict with their neighborhood plan
yeah
thank you that's very comprehensive and
didn't mind the reminder uh come about
first speaker please which is Mr John
Stark and Mrs Mary Stark
yep that's fine make yourself
comfortable
um
you've got three minutes and we'll give
you a warning uh with 30 seconds to go
if that's okay and if you could stay
there after you've spoken there may be
some questions for you so please don't
run away
thank you far away
26 years ago I got married in clavidan
to a man with vision he brought us with
a three-month-old baby to Hercules Farm
which had been declared unfit for human
habitation
using the highest quality materials he
created a beautiful family home that our
two sons have enjoyed all their lives
every member of the family has been
involved in and supported the village
both boys attended the local nursery and
school and played in local sports teams
I was clocked the school Governors for
five years and John served on the parish
council
in 2012 John secured planning permission
for a new sustainable Farm to be built
on our land we started the groundworks
and made the entrance but ultimately the
architect's designed for a building of
outstanding architectural interest
proved impossible to build within budget
so we cut back on our farming activities
and we stayed Where We Are
now with the boys moving on and John
living with health issues the large
house and farm is too much for us to
manage we wish to remain in clavidon but
have not found any properties locally
that would meet our needs John has once
again risen to the challenge and come up
with what we think is a solution that
would benefit both us and the village
the club neighborhood plan section 4
housing States the objective for
Claritin is to promote new high quality
homes in sustainable locations that meet
the needs of current residents without
compromising the attractive setting of
The Village
for one states that clavidin is
identified as a category 3 local service
Village
4-2 states that 26 new homes have been
identified since 2011. one of which has
been attributed to Hercules Farm but not
built
for three states as a Greenbelt Village
Development is restricted to small-scale
development which meets housing needs
and does not harm the openness of the
green belt and also allows limited
infill development
the application fulfills these criteria
and goes further
the entrance was created in 2012 and
approved by WCC highways who have also
approved it in respect of the current
application
proposed house is placed strategically
at 23 meters from the road using the
natural Topography of the land when
leveled off it would mean that the one
and a half story house would sit some
five meters below the level of the road
its position in the shadow of the
deciduous trees on the boundary would
provide cool shade in the summer and
energy-giving light in the winter
the house has a u value of 0.12 this
linked with ground Source Heating and
the latest most efficient perovskite
photovoltaic panels underground
rainwater collection
and mechanical air changing system which
collects around 80 percent of the heat
expelled from the building could result
in a passive house at Net Zero great
care has been taken with the design of
the house in keeping with the rest of
the village and no existing views would
be affected
thank you thank you very much that was
spot on
Brave ah Ken says have any any questions
for the upcoming please councilor cargo
housing needs
um is this part of the local housing
needs survey that was completed we all
completed the local housing needs survey
and that's part of the parishment
council's housing need that's correct
I can't see any further questions
thank you Mrs Mr Mr start you're free to
go thank you
right
and our next speaker is the ward member
um
chairman
five minutes catch the ridgids
thank you chairman
members to my mind this application has
many similarities uh to that of an
application we approved it Committee
just two weeks ago in snitchfield
it's in the green belt it meets in my
mind the definition of infill and
therefore is an exemption in Greenbelt
policy it's on previously developed land
and it has very special circumstances
attached to it the key difference
clearly is this is for a passive house
rather than Stables
now considering these points
individually the site itself sits
between Hercules Farmhouse and Piper's
Croft to the West right on the edge of
the village boundary built form
continues from Piper's cross along the
Henley Road to the junction of kington
Lane roughly about half a mile away from
the application site
to my mind this is clearly Limited
infill in the Greenbelt and the village
of clavidan
the site also benefits from an extent
permission from 2012 where a material
start was made regrettably the
undertaking of that build was so great
that the applicants were forced to cease
work and reconsider their plans evidence
of that material start however can be
seen on-site and indeed on Google Maps
the site is therefore considered to be
previously developed land
for both these reasons I believe the
application can be granted under the
exemptions to Greenback policy however
if you don't agree with me on that let's
now explore the special circumstances
that have been put forward
in the first instance the house has been
designed as a passive house with a u
rating of 0.12 or 0.13 making the
proposal as close to carbon neutral as
possible this is a fantastic opportunity
to help the climate crisis but also a
step in the right direction towards
future house building standards in this
District I also believe it would fit
under paragraph 80 of the mppf for its
architectural Merit
The Proposal is also a self-build scheme
we have a requirement as you know to
maintain level of self-building plots
across the district currently we fall
very short whilst this is just one
self-help property the weight I
attribute to the fact that there's
self-built is material
and finally the personal health
circumstances of the applicant should be
a material consideration and should be
considered as a very special
circumstance I'm not going to go into
the details of the applicant's condition
it wouldn't be right for me to do so
particularly in a public forum but I can
confirm that it is a respiratory issue
and the applicant has provided both
myself and I believe the office officers
with evidence of his declining Health
including a letter from embedical
professional detailing the need for
their daily use of specialized equipment
which could not be fitted into his
current listed property
the benefits of the passive house will
also contribute to alleviation of this
health condition
for me these points do amount to special
circumstances and therefore should be
given appropriate weight in the planning
balance if you are minded to support the
granting of this application I might
suggest a condition limiting the
property's use to the applicant and his
family specifically because of the very
special circumstances considered but
only if you require special
circumstances if you're comfortable that
it is limited infill on previously
developed land within the village
then we don't need to worry about that
condition
members until we heard from the update
sheet there was no objection for the
parish council that obviously has been
has changed there is no objection for
any statutory consulties and I am in
full support and I trust we can gain
your full support too thank you very
much
Council Richard so I I praise your
brevity there well within the five
minutes any questions for the ward
member please
Council Mills
a couple times you spoke about previous
uh developed land can you expand on that
so in 2012 I think it was July 2012 and
you'll see it in your report there was a
permission was granted for a substantial
property to be built on that land
um I I haven't got the benefit of Google
map in front of me but I'm sure we could
get a picture up you'll be able to see
the material start that was made it was
a substantial property
um as I say about how the work had to be
ceased and the applicants have been
exploring other options this is another
option
the permissions extant and they could
continue with the development of that
land because it is it is extant but the
moment they're choosing not to they're
choosing to go down this line
cancer
developed London the previous permission
was that for a farm did I pick that up
from these speakers
um I would get your officers to confirm
that I don't believe it was for a farm
it was certainly for a um
a substantial and rather impressive
building that's all I can tell you right
now
could we raise that point of
clarification against the cargo
this is what I like to see brevity well
done this is very impressive
um any other questions for the ward
member
thank you councilor thank you very much
all right well
move swiftly on to points of
clarification to offices and I believe
that kicks the cargo might have a point
there's the cargo do you want to raise
your point in points of clarification no
the only one was only actually update
this sorry in your um summary on page
eight so it actually States it was
construction of a new Farmhouse with
integral agricultural buildings so thank
you
yeah I just want to
could that be considered a a sort of
Quasi fallback position can you give
some clarification on what that status
the the extent planning permission I
think one of the tests for a fallback to
be considered a fallback would be that
it's likely to occur and we've we've
heard from the applicant that they're
unable to implement it so I don't think
we would accept it as a fallback
position in this case
because there's no realistic Prospect it
would be implemented if we didn't Grant
planning permission for this
previous planning permission is still
extended it is extant yeah but we
understand they can't open it due to the
cost
okay
thank you chairman uh could the officers
tell us the frontage width of the
property please as an infill has been
suggested and the second point is the
naval development plan
has presumably been adopted since the
grant of applying permission to The
Farmhouse I wondered if you could just
confirm that I'll take your questions in
reverse order if I know that the
collaborative neighborhood plan was made
in 2019
um
so it's an adoptive plan it holds
greater weight than the core strategy
because it was more recently adopted
um in terms of the width of the frontage
do you mean the width of the building
itself or the width of the application
site I'm seeking to clarify
um
the suggestion that way up the infill
argument
um it would help me to know if the width
of the plot is five meters or 50 meters
so the definition of infill that's used
in applications that have been assessed
before and peel or whatever is um
the development of an otherwise built up
Frontage in a small Gap
beyond that small in inverted Commerce
it interpret that as you know there
won't be a definition of small it will
be a matter of planning judgment in the
context
thank you chairman
catch the happy place
[Music]
mentioned paragraph 80 of the nppf
for the benefit of all councils could
you remind us what that says and what
the the Merit of his argument that he
was seeking to put yes paragraph
actually the nppf says that planning
policies and decisions should avoid the
development of isolated homes in the
countryside unless one or more of a
number of circumstances apply one of
those circumstances may be that the
design is of exceptional quality in that
it is truly outstanding reflecting the
highest standards in architecture and
would help to raise standards of design
more generally in rural areas
and that it would significantly enhance
its immediate setting and be sensitive
to the defining characteristics of the
local area
I think our reasons for refusal relate
quite strongly to some of the issues
brought about by paragraph 80 and we
would suggest it's not a paragraph 80
sounds
thank you councilor Mills please
said on your um
your report about the landscape used
um where was that from was that from the
Henley Road
my photos were from the Henley Road yeah
right
um
on one of the photographs or a couple of
photographs of behind the road the trees
there so either side
so I just wondered if you could see the
site from
any road
okay okay so do you want me to get my
slide back up yeah or or the photographs
of um Kelly Road please
these ones
no they actually Henley Road itself
here that's it so yeah so I'm not
standing outside the application site
I've walked up the road here
um so the frontage of the application
site is shown
in this photo so you can get a sense
that it's very very open
um so that hedge is in is up the road
okay
I've got one um
regarding the special circumstances
regarding medical conditions
um we have to what
we have to be careful here obviously we
have given too much detail on in public
forum and we're able to scrutinize the
information that um you were sent in and
would that qualify our special
circumstances
so we
was
circumstances of the applicant
um these are medical reports and things
they weren't submitted so I've not had
eyes on them
um so I was aware that the applicant was
in need of a some accommodation where he
could you know get his treatment but
with regards to what um was said by
councilor Richards I've not seen those
reports
um and in Greenbelt applications very
special circumstances don't usually
cover the medical circumstances of
applicants they are
yeah they usually don't come into that
and we would have to be satisfied if we
were to approve this
that this is the only site on which that
need can be met
um so yeah members can interpret that
I think that does answer the bar is very
high for very special circumstances as
members will appreciate and and it would
need to be you know
demonstrated Beyond doubt I think
through the evidence provided by the
applicant
um the very special circumstances
relating to their health conditions
required a development in this location
particularly
um to satisfy their needs
our view is that that's not been
provided through the course of the
application hence the recommendation
we've made
[Music]
and that they had been sent in these
reports yeah have not received them
okay can
okay
[Music]
sorry about that I was just checking
some legal advice and just some clarity
uh Mr and Mr Stark would you about to
come back up just so I can clarify one
point
foreign
I apologize for making you have to come
back up again but we want to get this
right so
um there was some slight confusion
around about the medical information and
what to get this ride could you tell me
were that against too much personal
detail what you sent in please
[Music]
in fact I'm going to carry out in Fusion
such as yeah because just
um the letters from the doctors or
something like that rather than natural
yeah
two of them from Immunology at
heartlands hospital
to them with two two pages each
and I'm giving greater detailed
structure
okay that's great thank you very much
sorry I apologies for I'm making you
come back up but certainly just wanted
to make real quick
thank you thank you right uh apologies
for that and the slide delay but I think
it was a person that we got to
got the information right we'll now move
on to the debate who wants to start
councilor Dixon thank you very much
thank you chairman
um
Greenbelt uh it is an area which is uh
presently safeguarded
uh the plot as we can see on the
diagrams and pages on page 23 obviously
a very large area
um obviously uh this uh comments made
regarded as infill
I'm sorry I can't uh accept that
personally I can see it's on the edge of
of clavidan yes Piper's Croft is at the
far side of it but when I actually also
look at the planning history
um shown on page eight
um obviously after the uh commission was
granted for the Farm building uh to be
replaced the new Farmhouse Etc they had
permission for that and then they
followed that with applications for six
Muse dwellings
demolition of the farm buildings and six
new Israelis to include to affordables
demolition of that direction of five uh
applications withdrawn
appeals dismissed I would not like to
see the whole of this plot regarded as
infill because I think in truth
um the moment or if we did acquiesce the
concept that the whole of that field
could be developed as infill then I
think we're on a very slippery slope
um and therefore
I personally can't accept that uh as a
or go against the officer's
recommendation in respect of uh
objections to the green Greenland uh
Greenfield science Etc is that a
proposal cancer Dixon I would support
the officer's recommendation to refuse
yeah per person yeah
happy about soon
right uh councilor Adam and councilor
Curtis please
I do a chord with councilor Dixon's take
on
it not being in the field but equally
listening to councilor Richard's uh
moving that on towards the special
circumstances I'm perhaps not entirely
comfortable with
just refusing it I have right here right
now so I'd be minded to propose that we
defer this for that information to come
forward
but that's up to other people to decide
to support the otherwise thank you very
much um can I just have some reason
proposal for the deferral and would it
be forsaken additional information
because
the special circumstance
is clear in person
um
or potentially clear in person and that
may affect our judgment
on how we how we see this as a whole
that's all I've got okay catch the
Curtis please thank you
this is very difficult but I'm inclined
to agree with councilor Dixon on this
and I think recalling one an officer
comment I don't think this has it's been
satisfactorily demonstrated that this is
the only site looking at the special
circumstances in which that need could
be met I don't think that's been
sufficiently clearly demonstrated so I
would be inclined to go along with the
officer's recommendation on this as well
would you be winning the second cancer
Dixon's proposal I think yes I I it is
very difficult but I in this instance I
would second that proposal thank you
Council cargo please
first I'll just save one record before
thank you very much indeed uh very
comprehensive
the element of Enfield I don't agree
with it is in so it can't be conceived
as such the other problem we've had over
many many years in the planning uh
planning applications is the personal
need and it's always a trick on it
that's it's an emotional argument but
the officers have said it there that the
bar is set deliberately very high for
those circumstances personal
circumstances and I'm afraid to say that
I feel that the the personal
circumstances no doubt weigh the need
for the the the harm that would be
caused both to the list of building and
to the openness and the green belt so I
can't I can't um support this I have to
go with the officer's recommendation
okay cancel cancel please
yeah um it is a tricky one um
I agree with Council Adam here um we we
are going a bit blind on this that not
knowing I don't want to know all the
facts but um the fact that
it was said that these reports were sent
in the medical reports and nobody seems
to know anything about it
um
to me there are exceptional
circumstances in all you know in many
planning applications I think we had one
um last year it was exceptional and we
granted it
um
so perhaps we could
sometimes we Patrick could defer this
until we get the information on this
because it is extremely tricky and since
the other planet applications perhaps
ill health is is deteriorated since all
the other applications are coming so a
couple of things here so first the
Ru seconding cancer evidence proposal
yes I would like to Mr chairman thank
you and if committee bears with me I'd
like to to slightly go back for points
of clarification with officers I know
we're into the debate so I do apologize
um I'm sorry about this um
I'm just making sure that
the information is sent in or is found
we use semantics as our apologies
um that
how much material white will it have on
the on the debate the actual decision
uh recommendation
I think the likelihood is that we would
recommend refusal in any case
um I think that we are concerned that
the scale of the building that's being
proposed here is very substantial
um
we have had I think we have had some
information about the um
personal circumstances of the applicant
but case law has held widely that such
circumstances don't usually pass the bar
required to be very special
circumstances where we're looking for
very special circumstances we have to
weigh the harm to the green belt and any
other harm and in this case we've
identified at least three other reasons
for refusal so there's you know there is
other harm that needs to be weighed
against it and so I think
the bar is corresponding and pushed even
higher in this case so I think although
we may defer and we may get further
information I think it's unlikely to
change office's recommendation in this
case
thank you and we'll go back into the
debate now apologies I thought we need
to clarify that catch the rock please uh
thank you chairman I think we've had the
clarification that I was looking for
from the officers that the exceptional
need in a very high bar we heard earlier
on and I too have the sympathy with the
personal circumstances but we have to be
very aware of personal circumstances and
personal pleading we we get we get
warned
about how difficult those are um and uh
I would I would move to a vote on the
first uh first proposal from
councilor Dixon uh for refusal I would
support the opposite recommendation
I can't see anybody else wishing to
speak so I'm happy to request through
your comments
um requests to cancel the rock so we'll
we'll is everybody happy if we go to the
vote on the first proposal which is
councilor Dixon's and seconded by
caps the Curtis to go with officer's
recommendation all those in front of it
please
against
and abstentions one
so committee resolves to refuse
application 220 to 493
all right
I'm good so
slightly I will still again
committee resolves to refuse uppercase
in
22-02493 fuel and I will pass on to the
capable of hands of cancer ridges
[Music]
okay are we good okay thank you very
much indeed for that let's look at our
next item which is application in
reference 2201937 ful land adjacent to
fully through the close in lower Quinton
um members we have no registered
speakers on this so we are in a position
to be able to delegate so I propose that
we do delegates because of secondary
councilor Eden quick show of hands
that is unanimous so we have therefore
delegated uh that application marvelous
Planet you can go ahead now
okay so we will then move to our next
application which is application
reference
2103090 ful and
21.03901 LBC that's Amscot old
Meetinghouse and illington Road in
armscott our presenting officer is
Stuart McIver Stuart as soon as you're
sat ready and comfortable over to you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you chairman
uh the pros or perform members is
restoration and change of use of listed
building to single dwelling with
Associated Works widening of his
existing access to accommodate new Drive
correction of bike and Bin store
so we have here a location plan and you
can see the application site denoted by
the black dot within the village of
armscope
so we just go on to a slightly smaller
scale again showing the location you can
see the application site outlined in red
here you can see the proposed building
for the change of use in red here
so we're on the East and outskirts of
the village of armscope you've got the
arms coat Road running north to south
just adjacent to the site here and then
you've got the ilmington road which runs
uh west to east just to the north of the
application site
and you've got residential development
to the South West and north of the
application so
and then we have the proposed site
layout plan
uh illustrating the proposed dwelling
here and then you've got a gravel drive
uh the access and the proposed bin and
bike store
and then we just go on to uh some
proposed elevations
and then we've got proposed section and
floor plan uh as you can see the floor
plan uh proposes just to use uh just
that the dwelling we utilize the uh
ground floor of the building
and then just as a comparison we have
um these are the superseded proposed
elevations as originally submitted with
the application
uh and then again
um just as a bit of comparison we've got
these superseded uh proposed sectional
floor plan so you can see that the um
the application originally uh
proposed uh the insertion of a first
floor to facilitate the change used to
residential
and then we just go into some images of
the application site so this is from the
arms coat Road just looking West into
the application site so you've got the
building just in the background
uh and then we just go on to another
image this is just taken from the north
of the site but on the ilmington road uh
so we're looking West and you've got the
proposed building for the change use to
residential here
and then again just another uh site site
image uh so this is from the arms coat
Road looking South
and then you've got the application site
um just the right here
and then again just the final site photo
just showing from within the application
site itself just showing the uh the the
building for the proposed Chaser use
so in summary the proposed restoration
and change of use of the building to a
single dwelling with Associated works
complies with policy as10c in that the
existing building is within the physical
confines of the village in terms of the
historic environment the amended
proposal includes the emission of the
first floor element and then and avoid
the internal subdivision of the building
and as such is less intrusive
than previously proposed therefore the
proposed works are considered to
preserve the special historic interests
of the grade 2 listed building and as
such is recommended that planning
permission and listed building consent
are granted
uh please refer to the update sheet for
updates regarding tree works and Parish
Council comments thank you chairman
Marla Stuart thank you very much indeed
let's call our first speaker on this
item who is Mr Ian Wilson of tradington
Parish Council
good evening Miss Wilson
and once you're sat and comfortable
you'll have three minutes as I said
earlier if you speak straight into the
microphone it'll pick you up I'll give
you a 30 second warning before time is
up um and if you could stay seated
afterwards of questions that'd be great
otherwise when you're ready floor's
yours thank you chair
um so the old meeting house has
considerable historic value to the
Hamilton armscott and The Wider wattage
community and Beyond
it was built in 1670 and has remained
relatively unchanged since then
it's a rare Testament to the Quaker
movement and provides a small open area
in the hamlet which until quite recently
was open the accessible to the armscope
community
Parish Council objects this application
as it will segment the interior of the
building and destroy the plane and open
space associated with the Quakes
meetings it will also obscure the
character of the original building
filling in the porch will take away a
key characteristic and all that will be
left of the original structure will be
two external walls on the roof
Additionally the proposed dwelling
constrained to original footprint will
be very small and will certainly not
provide a good standard of space and
amenity for occupiers as required by
policy cs9
as armscot is classified as an all of
the settlement development is restricted
to small-scale community-led schemes
while this is a small scale it is not a
community-led scheme as evidenced in the
recent how the news survey carried out
in January 2020 in which Oscar was the
only community in the parish not to
identify a need for any housing
in the emerging neighborhood plan the
site has been identified as a local
Green Space and is supported by the
residents and independent planning
consultant
it represents one of the few Open Spaces
left within the Hamlet which residents
do not want developed and as such should
be preserved it is close to the
community it is demonstrably special to
the low Community because of its
historic association with the Quakers it
is a tranquil site and has a richness of
Wildlife
planning was granted in 2008 for an
estate office but this was never
followed through before and after this
several applications were made to
convert the meeting house into a
dwelling but none have been approved
the parish council accepts that
something must be done with the building
to protect this unique structure and to
preserve its Heritage however it would
like to see something more sympathetic
to the original use of the building that
will preserve as much as the original
structure as possible
the development is within a graveyard
with no Mark Graves yet no information
has been supplied on how this sensitive
matter will be addressed
we believe the tree report is incorrect
and inaccurate compared with the most
recent application refused in 2020 for a
conversion to a dwelling this site
includes a number of trees with tree
preservation orders and we believe the
inaccurate plan does not take account of
the potential route protection area
the value of this building lies in
preserving as much of its original form
as possible and this application doesn't
do that 30 seconds the parish council
therefore rejects the application being
approved
I always give that warning just as
people finish typical isn't it Mr Wilson
tank very much members do we have any
questions seraphim first please
um is this building used for any purpose
at all
how long has it been not used you know I
I couldn't tell you that but um when
councilor Harvey speaks he will be able
to uh okay thank you Council cargo
again uh it has been used in the past by
by residents
um uh not entirely sure exactly what
foreign was open to Residents again
Council Harvey can probably expand
couldn't expand on that and the other
thing I'd just like to Open HF
um the parish plan you mentioned that
that is it's a green open space again
can you just uh so the neighborhood plan
is currently uh in consultation and this
has been identified an open space within
the plan uh and it's it's it's the final
stages of consultation so there's like
to be a referendum on on the plan in uh
in May June time
okay any other questions members
no Mr Wilson thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
okay so our next speaker is a Mr Trevor
Harvey
speaking as a resident I believe
is that correct indeed marvelous okay Mr
Harvey you'll have three minutes I'll
give you 30 second warning when your sat
come from ready to go that time is yours
um before I start could you helpful to
me if you could admit the 30-second
warning I'm aware of it I will admit to
a 30-second warning and I will cut you
off on your time is up
whenever you're ready
thank you Mr chairman
this application represents another
attempt to squeeze a court into a pint
pot this is a proposal to convert not to
conserve
the old meeting house is the last
purpose-built Quaker Meeting House in
the district that has not either been
converted or added to it's Unique
in dismissing a simple similar
application to convert the building in
2004 the planning inspector pointed out
that the old meeting House's simple form
reflects the Simplicity of the Quaker
religion it housed and it is an
essential part of the special interest
conversion to a dwelling would
inevitably compromise a simple
utilitarian character of this single
cell building the essential character of
the building is sensitive to any
intrusion
this proposed conversion compromises the
building's simple form the setting of
the building would be harmed by its
domestication this proposal fails to
meet the requirements of section 16 of
the nppf in numerous ways I'll give just
two examples first Power 190 sets a
two-legged test that requires that any
proposal should both sustain and enhance
the significance of the relevant
Heritage asset this proposal to infill
the Victorian veranda and tarmac over
the barrel ground doesn't either it
radically rather than minimally changes
the appearance of the building and
compromises its historic significance it
would also damage its setting by
threatening protected trees removing
ancient Hedges and domesticating the
setting of a burial ground second
example is power 199 requires that
irrespective of the level of harm great
weight should be given to the assets
conservation this proposal doesn't
conserve it alters and spoils the third
reason is that this proposal doesn't
meet the terms of CS5 because it would
cause visual scar Within armscope by the
removal of a section of ancient hedge
fourth there are no substantial public
benefits as required by cs-8 to outweigh
the harm caused none the only benefits
to be had here are private benefits
fifth the cramp facilities do not
provide a good standard of space and
Immunity for occupiers as required by
cs9 six The Proposal fails to Accord
with as10 because igniter meets a
defined local need nor is it supported
locally seventh the tradington NDP is at
regulation 16 stage and therefore worthy
of moderate weight the NDP has
identified the old meeting house as the
single proposed local Green Space in
Amscot seven planning reasons to refuse
Mr chairman based on the requirements of
the nppf the core strategy and the NDP
please take your pick
Council Army thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for Mr
Harvey councilor Dixon please
um the
local neighborhood plan describing this
as an open local Green Space and
certainly looking at the photographs the
building itself seems to be the mining
unit within quite a large space
obviously
conserving a historic building is
appropriate
have the community ever
tried to learn with your knowledge glean
ownership of the building in order to
retain it Etc because obviously if
nothing is allowed to happen to it it
could just simply disappear
um
the meeting house is privately owned by
an individual who owns Amscott Manor
he originally he did own the next door
property of beecroft
um he sold beecroft off
um
the the
Green Space that the meeting has
provides has been used communally at the
behest of the owner
the owners never made it uh as far as I
would have never made any intention
clear that he wants to sell it in fact
quite the opposite he's repeatedly
brought in applications to seek to do
something with it
um the reason why he didn't pursue the
granted office accommodation notice
office not residence was because he
wanted him he decided that it wasn't big
enough for his purpose and he built
opposite the fuzzy dock he took down a
Victorian we're straying into things
that are not related directly to this I
appreciate you being very careful with
your choice of words so I'd like to draw
this bit to a closer we can and get to
the focused point please the owner has
never attempted to sell it or put it on
the market as far as I'm aware so the
community have never approached it I
guess thank you any other questions from
Mr Harvey councilor Foreman please
well you said that this was about site
there are
it is a burial it is a burial site if
you if you go to any of the literature
on quakerism in South Warwickshire you
will find reference to this as a burial
site
and we don't know how long ago it was
used as a burial site from well from
there is no record of burials as such
there are references in historical
archives to it being a burial ground it
it was used that building was used from
the the early 18th century
but there are no recorded burials
there are no I know of no records okay I
know of literature historical literary
literature which refers to it being a
burial ground thank you we will probably
seek some more clarification from our
officers shortly anyone else with a
question for Mr Harvey before we move on
no Mr Harvey thank you very much for
your time contribution
okay we'll hear from our final speaker
on this item who is our agent Miss
Miranda Rogers
thank you
uh Miss Rogers are you I think you know
the drill you've been here plenty of
times before you have six minutes uh do
you want your 30 second morning
I should be all right okay I will
refrain from giving you a warning
otherwise whenever you're ready I will
start the clock as soon as you start
speaking the floor is yours
I'm very impressed with your new
speakers by the way thank you they are a
huge Improvement
but I need to remember to say good
evening because that way it triggers it
and I can hear what people are saying
because quite often we're missing the
first few words that are being said by
people
so you just say good evening first every
time so okay
um the old meeting house is a unique
listed building which has been in the
ownership of the applicant for about 15
years during that time the owner has
tried to maintain it and indeed has on a
number of occasions allowed local people
into the site and into the building
however it's now had no proper use for
Community or otherwise for over 20 years
and is in too poor a state of repair to
allow people to enter with no income to
repair and then maintain it it continues
to deteriorate
your conservation officer in
pre-application consultation in 2021
confirms that it is important to find a
new occupant to maintain viability
sustain significance and secure its
preservation the advice continued that
the preferred use is one which maintains
its architectural integrity and identity
and which avoids internal and external
alteration
a community use was the preferred option
but Amscot has just 52 dwellings which
provides insufficient people to sustain
a community building which is already
operational let alone one that requires
significant expenditure such a hall
might be used by a wider Community but
with halls in Newbold tredington and
Blackwell there simply isn't the demand
here
if a public use isn't viable the
conservation officer noted that any
alternative use which avoids disruptive
alterations could be acceptable
including residential if the open plan
layout of the main hall is preserved and
extensions are avoided
the residential skin before you has the
support of your conservation officer
there are no extensions and contrary to
assertions by others the open plan form
of the main hall is preserved together
with the historic pews a single bedroom
and bathroom are provided in the lean
too which would be largely glazed to
maintain its historic appearance this
approach was advocated by your
conservation officer and indeed
historically the lean-to was at least
partially clad
very few alterations are therefore made
internally or externally
beyond the building a small Drive is
provided to accommodate two cars and a
shed to accommodate bicycles and
electrical vehicle charging Point these
are kept away from the building and the
bare minimum to meet your development
requirements the conservation officer
concludes the design of the modest
garden shed is acceptable it will not
compete or detract from the chapel
building the gravel surface not tarmac
is and area is minimal and will not
disrupt the disrupt the Chapel's setting
um I would accept that these changes
will have some impact on the Heritage
asset it's inevitable but I ask you to
recall the need to find an alternative
use and consider what other uses would
require any use will require heating
lighting the provision of water and wc
facilities which means alteration and
the enclosure of the lean-to every youth
requires parking and any other use will
require a greater level of parking than
a one-bedroomed dwelling
where a range of uses all have the same
impact your conservation officer advises
that it is for the applicant to
determine which is the most appropriate
in this case a residential conversion is
deemed to have the least impact on the
Heritage asset making it the most viable
use for the building
supervision of a new dwelling within the
confines of the settlement through
conversion Accords with policy as10c and
therefore has received your office's
support
there are obviously concerns I'm just
going to touch on a couple of them
graveyard objectives have stated there
may be burials within the site there is
separate legislation that deals with
this and consideration is not therefore
a relevant planning matter but that
notwithstanding a written scheme of
Investigation could be secured by
condition to mitigate the loss of any
potential archaeological remains
including burials a similar situation
arose in the consideration of a
replacement dwelling in Nook Cottage and
lower brailles on a former Quaker burial
ground where an appropriate condition
was attached to mitigate any potential
burial Farms fines local Green Space the
site is not currently designated as a
local Green Space and the emerging
neighborhood plan cannot be given a
great deal of weight it is it yet it has
yet to be independently assessed
if the site were to be so designated
Greenbelt policy would apply which
supports the conversions of buildings to
alternative uses such as that being
proposed the listed building status
would prevent the erection of any
outbuildings meaning the green open
character would not change
trees this application has been
significantly delayed whilst trees and
hedgerows have been resolved this
included the submission of an updated
tree report which your landscape officer
has accepted she has been significantly
involved with this and the result is a
retention of protected trees as well as
several other trees the internal drive
was realigned to avoid root protection
zones and the proposed conditions will
ensure the retention of the trees
loss of the Hedgerow County highways set
specific requirements for visibility
displays on this site and that includes
the removal of around two meters of
existing Hedgerow the proposals include
replacement planting set back within the
site and your landscape officers have
concluded that the loss is adequately
mitigated again any alternative use of
the site would require at least the same
works and the size of the property and
future enlargement objectives note the
proposed Welling would be small and thus
there would be pressure on the council
to emit extensions in the future in fact
the dwelling will have a floor space of
over 80 square meters not a small
property particularly for a one bed and
nearly double the National Space
standards for a two-person one-bedroom
flat
the building is listed and again I
repeat there will be no permitted
development rates meaning any further
Works will require both planning
permission and listed building consent
so just to summarize the meeting house
is an important listed building there is
no likelihood of it being used as a
meeting space in the future the
condition is deteriorating and an
alternative permanent use must be found
the conversion to a dwelling Accords
with your core strategy and the proposed
scheme respects the building maintains
its key historical attributes and will
have limited impact on its physical
structure no alternative use will have
less impact and may well require greater
in
intervention apologies
um I have to ask you to wrap up there I
was just about to by saying the proposal
records with your development plan I
hope that you can grant plan permission
unless the building consent in with your
in accordance with your a recommendation
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our agent please
councilor Cargill first
um the first one is the changes that are
being proposed
um because it is a historic building are
they reversible
are they permanent changes to the
structure
remains appreciate that
um
the cladding I mean you will have to do
Works to convert this to anything at the
moment it is a poor condition Stone
building that's right I'll go back to
what you said
the officers
um the the Heritage officer said to
avoid internal and external alterations
that's what I'm trying to come to will
there be changes internally and
obviously we know some external that
will actually be permanent
there will be the inclusion of services
there will have to be leveling of the
floor and insulation and they will have
to be repair Works to the internals of
the roof because it is in such a poor
structural condition
um are they reversible well no but then
buildings have to be maintained included
listing listed buildings
um in terms of the important key
attributes apart from the shell
there is it is an open space we are
retaining an open space there is no
subdivision going on in the main hall
the important internal attribute is the
um
I think I'm going to stop you there
because you've probably answered the
question okay
um thanks please oh you've got another
one Council card
one is are there any excavations
external from the building in the
Redevelopment
we will require to lay a small Drive
which will of course involve the
movement of the soil and the leveling
but we're not digging down there is a
small shed going in to meet the bicycle
and electrical vehicle charging
requirements that presumably will go on
to a concrete plinth which will
effectively sat on the ground so in
terms of deep excavations no thank you
and finally cheers
do you know
um and you may not be able to answer
this when the last public use of the
green open space Wars please
it's it was lost it was sold by the
Quakers in
2000 not to my clients to other people
who were trying to do significant
development on it
my clients bought it following the
refusal and dismissal appeal in 2005.
and they have allowed
members of the local community to come
in perhaps once or twice a year to go in
the hall historically and they also
allowed people from the Quakers to go
into the building upon request so they
could ring up the building is no longer
safe and people are not permitted in
there at all but there's never been any
public access since it closed as a
Quaker Meeting House and that pre-dates
2000 I don't know exactly when
Castle Rock hey chairman and good
evening
um you anticipated one of my questions
by telling me it was 80 square meters
but you've also said that the main body
of the building will be maintained as an
open space
uh
so most of the
day-to-day occupation will be in the uh
the link to element of it do you know
what the proportions that's not right
okay sorry hang on can you let the
councilor finish asking his question so
do you know the proportion between the
main body and the lean two in terms of
square meters and you can please
elaborate if you need to is it possible
for the officer to put up a floor plan
that just shows the split in the
building so there is currently one main
room and then the lean to the main room
would provide all the living
accommodation so kitchen dining and
living if you could just zoom in onto
the bottom right hand
oh the bottom right hand drawing
you will see that the the main living
area is about two-thirds of the inside
of the building and then the lean two
provides the bedroom a bathroom and an
entrance hall okay got that thank you
chairman okay thank you councilor didn't
actually your finger go up for a
question okay in that case anyone else
got any questions
no Mr Rogers thank you very much your
time contribution this evening right
let's move to excuse me points for
clarification to our officers has anyone
got any points they would like
clarifying cancer Curtis first sorry
it's no point of clarification but I've
realized that I the applicant is known
to me I do know the app because I hadn't
appreciated that earlier but I approach
this wouldn't open mind I haven't seen
him for several years okay thank you
thank you anyone else punch
clarification cancer Mouse yeah thanks
Mr chairman um
the the
I'm sorry the building itself
um it's in it really dilapidated
condition if not nothing is done so it's
going to just fall apart is it
um is it that bad is it um uh bear with
me it probably helped if I bring out my
some of my site photos
that's probably the best site image of
the building
um
I obviously you get down to members to
sort of interpret
um so that's the state of the building
however when I went up and sort of did
my site visit
um it did appear to me uh as a as a
building in a state of disrespass so to
speak and were you able to go inside and
see it uh obviously too dangerous I
didn't go inside uh when I did my side
because it was a purely external site
visit
okay okay Council cargo please
we've mentioned
but this was the least impactful
development
[Music]
can you confirm that what what it means
as well please
um so originally there uh there was a
proposal when the application was
originally submitted which did include
uh uh insertion of the first floor to be
used for residential use as well
um which would have involved
um more internal Works to the list of
building
um which officers race concerns about uh
and therefore amended plans were
submitted which emitted the first floor
usage and it's purely on the ground
floor uh which is therefore minimizes
the impact on the list of the building
and following on to America nature
applications
2001790 and 2001 Sonic so restoration
one building was refused so have you
just answered that by saying that this
is this design is now saying so
significantly but you you were happy to
grant that
um planning permission on this one as
opposed to refuse it
so the previous so the application back
in uh that you refer to in 2020 involved
the
um extensioners of the building as well
it involved um it writes in a side
extension and this was considered to
have harmful impact on the on the the
setting uh and
um
visual impacts with the building so to
speak where's the the current proposal
doesn't propose an extension there's
there's minimal external works and
therefore that that is thought to retain
the I think I would just draw members
attention to the middle paragraph of
page 43 which concludes with the verbal
comments of the conservation officer
who's confirmed
will not cause harm to the special
interest of the little listed building
um
the
the Mrs Rogers suggested that permitted
development rights could would be
removed is that the case
Council Foreman please
on the bedrooms do we know that it was a
burial site and if so if the application
was to be granted what
measures will be put in place so
thank you so officers were aware that
um it potentially was a Quaker burial
ground
um
given this the extent of the scheme
and the fact that the proposal includes
um
the provision of a gravel driveway which
I think we've already heard will require
a minimal sort of deep excavations to
the site and the provision of a bin bike
store again minimal uh
excavations of the site
um we didn't deem it necessary to uh
seek a further archaeological survey so
to speak however if members were willing
to
um Grant permission we could obviously
put a condition on uh in terms of a
written scheme of Investigation in case
any sort of occurrences come up during
the um during the proposed works thank
you just following off from that if I
may if one if we were minded to include
an archaeological survey presumably that
would require quite material amounts of
being of land and could significantly
damage the setting of the building by
virtually the fact that we're digging up
all the garden is that a fair assessment
I think the most likely scheme of
Investigation would result in a watching
brief so they would undertake the works
with minimal intrusion but there would
be somebody on site potential so we
would know how to deal with any
archeology that merged of course of
those works I mean I had a horrible
vision of all that being
cancer Mills
usually with uh any
um burial site the the plots are marked
out somewhere it must be there must be a
piece of paper saying where the where
the barrel sites are where the graves
are
all so I think I think I would tend to
agree that I would expect that sort of
thing but as we've heard from a number
of our speakers and indeed our officers
we don't have access to that I think the
only logical thing that one could do is
to consider an archaeological survey or
as and as we've heard as a watching
brief rather than anything else
um Council Foreman
foreign
I might ask you to continue that in
debate which we're about to go into
unless anyone has a point of
clarification
nope in that case Council form would you
like to start us off with a debate and
maybe continue with what you're saying I
was just going to say that we have
um a burial Cemetery in Ulster where we
have no
um records of where the graves are but
that actually are Graves there and you
can have a ground survey which is which
is doesn't
dig into the ground all they've got
machines that can go over the top and
survey and see that there are Graves
there so okay Council Rock
thank you get our propose first of all
that we do including the recommendation
before we make a decision to written
screen of Investigation which need not
be intrusive speaking from experiences
had one
um and in terms of the debate I asked
the question about the size
because I am concerned about the
modifications to what has been called
the lean to because that seems to be a
Mr Harvey showed us the original
pictures from 1800 or whatever but
obviously for a considerable period
we've had that lean to which now
contributes to what is now a unique uh
Heritage building it seems to me
and there seems to be very fun
fundamental changes by enclosing that
and when we don't enclose that we end up
with
a bit of a question mark about the
viability of this as a dwelling
so I'll listen to what everybody else
has said but I I think I'm I'm unminded
it's not an appropriate use and I tend I
find myself in a disagreement with
Heritage Archives this is such an
invaluable building it seems to me in
terms of the Heritage aspects of the
district
that um I think it's it's too Draconian
a change
just so I'm clear
um
you've proposed an inclusion of the
archaeological survey on a written brief
yep for that WSI yeah were we minded to
Grant the application that you're not
proposing to Grant not and you're also
not proposing them
you're listening but you've just given
some months okay I just wanted to
understand thank you thank you who would
like to go next councilor Curtis oh
sorry actually councilor Adam did signal
ages ago I do apologize councilor Eden
sorry you're hiding behind how's the
Cargill
um
I feel that it is quite elegant and
sensitive I'll be honest to to the
listed building
um I think that the
uh works for the the driver
unintrusive I'd like to see the
condition that we've talked about about
the watching brief for that kind of
thing so
with all that in mind to save it seems
better than to let it rot away
um and you know I don't say that that
lightly I live in a listed building
myself
um
so I I'm happy to go with the officer's
recommendation with that extra condition
and proposal we Grant
thank you very much indeed councilor
Curtis please thank you and
I think this is tricky I'm just looking
at policy cs9 and sort of agreeing with
councilor Rock to a degree here that you
know proposals that that is very
distinctive
as it stands with that lean to as shown
in that photo composers that were
damaged or destroy features which
positively contribute to local
distinctiveness will not be permitted
um I think it's a it's a fine balancing
act on this one
um
I'm not hearing a proposal either way
there no it sounds like we're going
towards the
the
the
refusal you think this is a very
difficult
we've got a listed building that is
deteriorating and how we best preserve
that I think is it's a very difficult
I'm not neither proposing nor in the
interest of getting things going
um I'm going to Second counselor Adam's
proposal
um I do find it very difficult and I
agree with a lot of what you you both
yourself and Council Rock have said
um
the frustration or the sorry the
difficulty I find is that um we want to
be preserving a listed building but
short of changing it or doing something
to it it's not going to be there anymore
because it is going to fall down at some
stage it might be now in a couple of
weeks it might be in a couple of years
we just don't know the reality is we
have to be able to adapt and change
otherwise that asset will no longer be
there um it will just be walls and
affording falling in roof so I'm going
to second with the inclusion of the um
of the archaeological survey
countercargill please
I've been listening to the debate and
all the arguments and I've been trying
to tease out all the changes that would
occur to this
in on balance I have to say I'd rather
see it preserved than fall down and it
would be a decent in use as long as we
are very careful about the excavation
works for example and things like that
and also I go with Council Rock that
that lean to is a feature of that
building now but I think filling it in
has been done and maintaining the actual
physical structure at least it's the
half back to what it did look in the in
the past and I don't I agree with you
Council which is that this is one of
those tricky balancing acts but I'm
happy to support the office of
recommendations marvelous thank you very
much can't answer seraphin yes um one
thing I do hate is buildings being empty
for so long and
there's no reason why anybody's going to
bring this back into a meeting room
the benefit of somebody living in there
without really increasing the footprint
I'll go with the office of
recommendation
marvelous I think we can move to a vote
we have a proposal to Grant with the
addition of the archaeological survey uh
it has of course been second date could
I please have a show now we're going to
take we have to take these individually
I'm afraid so this is for um the full so
2103090 ful uh could I have a share of
hands for those in favor of granting
with that additional condition please
to drink before
nine nine and against one with zero
abstentions
um so uh committee resolves to Grant
application
2103090 ful and then we need to take the
LBC the LBC is twenty one zero three
zero nine one LDC I'm going to propose
that we Grant along with the um
archaeological uh survey as before
cancer Edna you prepared to second that
again
marvelous um can I please have a show of
hands please in favor of granting that's
suggested nine and against one uh
committee therefore resolves to Grant
application twenty one zero three zero
nine one LBC
okay thank you very much
let's move to our next item
which is application reference
2100204 ful is land off far more Lane
um and west of the a435 Birmingham Road
in Redditch
our presenting officer is Louise Coleman
and Louise is yeah no problem as soon as
you're comfortable and ready you can
begin uh we of course we have
um
Dave Pilcher from our County Council
highways and our head of development
John careford who has joined us here for
questions as well should they be
required
Louise as soon as you're ready the floor
is yours
[Music]
thank you chair uh this is a cross
boundary application for the erection of
236 homes with open space Landscaping
drainage infrastructure and other
Associated works
210 homes full within Redditch Borough
and 26 homes within stratford-upon-avon
District the Redditch application
referenced 24 stroke zero one six five
zero ful was brought before their
committee on the 23rd of November and
was granted subject to the completion of
a section 106 agreement members are
therefore only considering the elements
which lie within Stratford District
which is the 26th unit
the site is located west of the a435
Birmingham Road East of far more Lane
and North of the
a4189 Warwick Highway straddling the
boundary between redditchboro Council
and Stratford on the Avon District
Council and it's situated approximately
5.5 kilometers east of Redditch Town
Center
the site which is the marked with the
red line is approximately 12.5 hectares
and comprises on of an irregularly
shaped tract of land immediately
adjacent to the Eastern Urban edge of
British the boundary line of Redditch
and Stratford runs north south through
the line with a pink hatched line
the site comprises of areas of open
grassland together with significant
areas of scrub and Woodland which is
predominantly made up of a poplar
Plantation planted in a grid pattern and
also areas of native Woodland
the site lies between far more Lane to
the West
poop which is here and the Birmingham
Road
uh to the east
and the southern boundary as I stated is
irregular informed by the a4189 Warwick
Highway
and a number of existing
um uh property boundaries to the north
the South South sorry a site is boundary
is defined by a small number of existing
residential cartilage is along with
short sections of field boundaries that
join a smaller tract of open land to the
north
beyond the a435 to the east lie to
substantial garden centers and a small
number of dwellings
the sight lies within the Arden special
landscape area in lies within the flood
zone one and a public sorry a footpath
it's not actually a public footpath but
a footpath runs through the site in an
East-West Direction and the site is
subject to a historic group TPO the land
falling within Stratford district is
allocated as a reserve housing site and
a policy uh sap for in the
stratford-on-avon revised preferred
options site allocations plan for
approximately 25 dwellings and the land
falling within Redditch borough is
identified as a housing allocation site
for 205 houses
this is an aerial view of the site and
the red line identifies the District
boundary with Redditch the areas of
mainly popular Plantation can be seen as
I stated in the grid pattern together
where the open grassland and shrub
the proposed layout plan is divided into
four slides to provide Clarity here
which shows the layout of the proposals
so this is the northern section the site
with the black hatch line identifying
The District boundary and the
development lying within Redditch which
has now been approved
the lands of the East includes an area
with a leap a community Orchard and
additional Woodland planting which is
within the Stratford District
the boundary so the layout provides a
hierarchy of roots with a central spine
road with secondary roads leading to
cul-de-sacs and Muse courts the red
stars identify areas of affordable
housing
the area for how sorry the area of
housing located within Stratford
district is primarily contained within
the two blocks within the Western part
of the site sorry the eastern part of
the site I should say a mix of one two
at three and four bed dwellings are
proposed throughout the site with 35
affordable dwellings within Stratford
District
this shows the southern part of the site
and the majority of which lies within
Redditch district with areas of open
space within Stratford together with a
lap and an additional attenuation basin
in order to facilitate the development
the proposals require the removal of
approximately 515 popular trees and 11
native trees as members and they're
identified by the pink areas on the plan
as members will note a large proportion
of these trees also fall within Redditch
Borough and are therefore already
authorized to be felled through the
granting of their application in
addition the forestry commission has
issued a felling license for the entire
site
the proposals include the retention of
existing native Woodland areas which are
identified on in brown on the plan
retention of existing native trees which
line the a435 Birmingham Road together
with their introduction of a new native
woodland landscape buffer along the
Birmingham road which extends between 28
meters adjoining the area where the
dwellings are proposed up to
approximately 95 meters in part for
example where the existing native
Woodland is being retained
and and also additional planting along
Farm or Lane
the proposals would result in the
planting of pro of of
600 native and ornamental trees
including a new community Orchard within
the north eastern part of the site
this is a landscape plan which
identifies areas of retained a new
native Woodland within the northeastern
part of the site the proposals as I said
include the provision of the lap as leap
apologies
um which is proposed to be surrounded by
a new community Orchard three drainage
attenuation basins are proposed with new
Wetland planting which is located within
the Eastern again the eastern
part of the development and in
attenuation Swale also is proposed along
along here with additional footpath
access into the site
linking new areas of public open space
so this is the other area again new
Woodland planting going in the lap and
additional drainage attenuation basin
[Music]
access into the site will be obtained
from far more Lane by three new right
hand turning Arrangements protected
either side by essential Refuge
this is one of the access points this is
the second one
and then a third
down here
a new three meter wide shared Footwear
cycleway is also proposed to be created
on the southbound side of far more Lane
connecting the site to existing
pedestrian links to Jesuit closed and
Berkeley close and you drop her
pedestrian Crossings are proposed the
central refuse areas to enable safe
Crossings onto sort of through far more
Lane
the dwellings are supposed to be
two-story with three bone glows within
the Redditch part of the development the
design and form of the dwellings draw
upon the Loca vernacular and they would
be constructed primarily a brick with
the use of some render and contrasting
roof tiles Ridge Heights are also
proposed to be varied to provide greater
interest within the street scene
these are a selection of the dwellings
types within Stratford District these
are the one bed mesonets
this is an example of a two-bed property
this is one of the three beds
and this is one of the four beds
um turning now to the photographs the uh
our self-explanatory uh going from light
left to right this is a view from far
more Lane
A View From the southern part from the
A4 uh 189 Warwick Highway view from the
north eastern part of the site so
looking from the Birmingham Road and
then again looking down the Birmingham
Road the A4 3-5 now this is looking
within the site itself from the existing
Woodland Poplar Woodland again to
another view closer Range View that
would the Woodland
um this is an area where the 26
dwellings would be located within this
vicinity uh the top right
um this is the path that runs through
the site and to the right is where the
um or 28 meters in
um this is where the proposal proposed
dwellings within Stratford District
would lie and then finally looking from
far more Lane at the pathway
um finally this is a view looking
towards the dog roundabout which is
mentioned in the report in The
Pedestrian Crossing that currently
exists across Birmingham road which
links to the footpath across the site
uh there are a number of updates for
members to note and chairman the
recommendation is to Grants planning
commissions subject to the completion of
a section 106 agreement however omitting
the requirement for any Financial
contribution to the commentary and work
that Berkshire clinical commissioning
group enlighted their updated uh
comments uh removing their requirements
for an obligation and in addition the
conditions and notes as detailed in the
report thank you chair Louise thank you
very much indeed let's go for our first
speaker on this item who is councilor
Maureen Berry of map of a green Parish
Council
good evening and welcome
we will bring those up in just a moment
[Music]
okay councilor Barry uh thank you very
much for being here thank you for your
patience while we got through us um if
you bear with us while we find the
slides for you and we'll get them up um
when we've got them up you'll have three
minutes do you want me to give you a 30
second warning
I think you're better
okay I will give you a 30 second warning
thank you
um and hopefully
cheese we'll have it in a second
is that what you were expecting yeah
um so will you refer to the slide one
slide two and so we'll know when to
change it is that okay yeah okay in that
case whenever you're ready the floor is
yours thank you uh thank you chairman in
this the parish council accepts that
most of the build form Falls within the
housing allocation in Redditch but argue
that such an allocation should also be
included or necessary infrastructure so
as not to rely on the land in the
Stratford District
more importantly despite being promoted
in the site allocation plan there is no
such adopted provision in Stratford
furthermore significant objections
remain to the site allocations plan and
little if any weight can be afforded it
as per your officer's report
the so-called need arising from
birmingham's housing needs is an
inaccurate due to the double counting of
students
the council has over eight years of
housing land so no need for Reserve
sites to come forward if a need is
required then mapleberry green has
provided this 25-5 houses during the
planned period with other sites suit
more suitable and available
a further 26 houses is excessive for
such a settlement within limited
services
there are more suitable settlements as
close to Birmingham that could provide
such provision the fundamental issue
with this development is the resulting
coalescence between mapleberry green and
Redditch this goes against the adoption
of the local plan where David Nash
formed the policy manager confirmed
there is no cross-border agreement and
the inspector agreed
both council's landscape Consultants
argued the site is in a high sensitive
zone for Housing Development most of the
area had been planted with Woodland to
provide a buffer between mapleberry
green and Redditch developing this land
would erode this Gap and necessitate the
removal of trees that are sensitive to
the landscape changing the character of
the route of the a435 that would
therefore be inappropriate for this
development the slides that are shown up
there at the bottom are the if you take
the Hedge the buffer is the tree
plantations you take those trees down
there isn't then no but for a tour or
screening between mapleberry green and
red it should just be open Countryside
the applicants argue that a buffer is to
be maintained but their plans clearly
show this buffer comprising of open
space ponds whales and Wildlife Meadows
with only a limited scrub planting and
tree Woodland planting this is in stark
contrast with the Woodland it exists
today 30 seconds
the existing headphone trees referenced
by the applicant to be retained along
the a435 is sparse and in poor condition
once the Poplar put Woodland is removed
the build form of Redditch would be
prominent from the a4355 thus resulting
in an unacceptable blurring of the two
dist distinct settlements the landscape
settlement with the harm would be
significant and irreversible so to lose
so to the loss of the ecology at the
time when the impact of the climate
change is so obvious there is also it
remains concern over ground conditions
and constructions reality afraid that is
your time so I'm going to have to ask
you to wrap up I'll give you a couple of
seconds to wrap up right finally when
applying their planning balance the
presumption in favor of the
sustainability of the development and
the benefits of this development do not
outweigh the significant and
irreversible environmental harm it would
cause we respectfully ask the members to
refuse this application accordingly
thank you very much I've given you 10
seconds over so I'm going to have to
afford that to everyone else I'm afraid
um members do we have any questions for
Miss Berry please or Council Barry I
should say
no in that case can spray thank you very
much for your time contribution and your
patience this evening thank you okay
let's call our next speaker who is Mr
Mark Crompton I believe or potentially a
mark Wallace I'm not sure
and now I understand you're from win
Yates green resident Association is that
correct
that is correct marvelous
and which of you is which I am Mark
Wallace
um
sneaking it behind me okay so we've got
your mark Wallace and we've got Mark
Crompton is that correct yeah and I'm
the chair of the residence Association
and he is one of our members marvelous
um and are you going to be so you've got
three minutes under three minutes and 10
seconds now are you gonna have
um are you gonna split your time or are
you gonna well I think what we'll do is
um I've got some notes here that if I go
through and
um then Mark will uh fill in any gaps
that I might have missed all around
right yeah in that case as soon as
you're ready do feel free to go I'll
give you a 30 second warning and then
I'll close you off at the three three
minutes and 10 seconds thank you
whenever you're ready okay thank you
very much
um I'm going to start by saying that
Michael Gove the Secretary of State for
the housing and communities he said very
recently that all new developments
should be more beautiful have the
consent of the local community be
accompanied by the right infrastructure
and protect the environment now let me
address that last Point first
currently mapperable Woods is a wood
um not just the popular trees but the
scrub land and also other nature you
know nature areas around
there are
um bats all sorts of proper English
Wildlife that we find in that area
now I know that the developers are
proposing to actually replace
um a lot of that with Native planting
but that doesn't get away from the fact
that
first of all they've got to get rid of
all the existing
planting
it gets rid of the existing environment
and therefore destroys the habitation
for the Wildlife that is there
when you actually put then in new
planting
and you're putting it in on a housing
estate I think it's very unlikely that
we're going to see the diversity of
wildlife that we currently have
returning to that area because it will
be very much changed
secondly the right infrastructure well
at the moment
um the the local community uh there is
no supporting infrastructure available
all the local health centers are
completely full
um it is difficult to get a doctor's
appointments and the local schools are
full
so
I don't know where any other provision
of the infrastructure is going to come
from
then we get to the first point which is
have the consent of the local community
now we were informed that they had
actually tried to contact us but
um there was no
um
no sort of consultation with us up till
very very recently
um and an invitation was extended to uh
join us at one of our residence meetings
on the 2nd of December but no
representatives were able to come
30 seconds
do you want to add anything Mark um yes
I will add one thing to it
the current map of rural Greenwoods as
it stands all the development will cars
and traffic will go on far more line it
is not suitable we already have enough
problems with traffic up there at the
top of the road with it already having
the council involved because of the
state of it with the amount of traffic
it is only going to get worse and nobody
has listened to anybody the people of
windy Oaks green or mapleberry green
they've just blank shot over everybody
and I'm afraid it's caused a lot of
upset sorry if this doesn't go down with
your approval but it really needs to be
turned down and something better needs
to be considered promise thank you very
much indeed and that is exactly the
amount of time I gave the previous
speaker so that's perfect thank you
members do we have any questions for our
two marks
no
gentlemen thank you very much for your
time contribution and of course your
patience this evening okay our next
speaker in this item is Mr Gary Goodwin
our applicant
Mr Goodwin would you like to make your
way forward
thank you very much indeed now Mr
Goodwin um we uh we would normally give
you six minutes we've obviously gone
over on a couple of the others we're
going to give you six minutes and 15
seconds
um use as much as or as little as if you
want like whenever you're ready the
floor do you want a 30 second morning by
the way no I don't think so whenever
you're ready thank you uh chairman
members thank you for the opportunity to
speak my name is Gary Goodwin and I'm
the group planning and director for
Morris homes limited the application
before you today represents the
culmination of two years of
collaborative working with your officers
since it was submitted but it's also the
compilation of over 10 years of working
in partnership with Holmes England and
both your own Council and reddish
Borough Council to ensure the site could
come forward as a collective housing
delivery program
obviously trying to summarize the six
minutes all the work everyone has put in
today it is now an impossible but we
appreciate the very comprehensive
reports that both your officers and the
officers are Reddish put together and
concluding with their recommendations
for approval
the starting point for the principle of
this development was the allocation of
the site for the hap for housing in the
Redditch local plan in order for that to
take place there was an environmental
impact assessment carried out and
consultations took place with the
councils as well as with both councils
as well as bodies such as the
environment agency Natural England
County Highway authorities and the local
communities we ourselves provided
indicative schemes and reports of the
planning inspector to show how the site
could be accessed and how it could be
developed and these were not dissimilar
to what we've got before you today
ultimately the allocation was supported
and granted by the inspector
as part of your own local plan process
we were initially asked to consider
three areas for additional homes within
the Stratford area but we ourselves
drastically reduce that
um to the small number of units that
you've got before you today so that we
could maximize the amount of retaining
Woodland Green infrastructure and create
the largest buffer possible and all of
that has now obviously been in front of
your site allocation plan and has formed
part of your cabinet's approval process
we realize this is a sensitive site and
a sensitive development particularly
amongst particularly amongst those
members of the public who hadn't
appreciated the advanced allocation
process but through the planning
applications we've sought to address
their concerns and those concerns raised
by the Consultants which I can Briefly
summarize so prior to the 1960s the site
was Open Fields with more native trees
along their boundaries and most of these
trees are being retained as part of the
development particularly along the a435
the poplar trees are non-native and they
were planted in 1965 and as you've seen
they're in a grid pattern they are in
poor condition they've reached the end
of their natural life and they are due
fulfilling and the forestry commission
have granted a license for those to be
failed
we've already heard how 600 new native
trees are going to be planted and it's
an area of 2.5 hectares of Woodland
compared to 1.1 hectares that's being
lost
which is a far better Legacy with
short-term prospects of the Poplar
Plantation at the moment
almost all the retained native trees and
the new Woodland Falls within the
Stratford part of the site and it forms
a very substantial buffer between 28 and
95 meters wide it also contains footpath
cycleways swales ditches sustainable
drainage features Community Orchards
Wildflower Meadows and that equates to
almost 40 percent of the entire site and
it all will be public accessible whereas
at the moment there's only very
restricted access
through the application process we've
proved that the site doesn't flood and
neither does it affect the Etsy marshes
and hence both Natural England and the
county council's lead for authorities
also support the application both County
Highway authorities both support the
application having now seen the
improvements that we're offering
particularly on far more Lane which was
experiencing speeding traffic and now
has pedestrian Crossings and slows the
speeds to 30 miles an hour
we've also embraced the changing
legislation coming forward and we're
we're in so such as the environment Bill
and we've we've embraced that and we now
have a biodiversity Net game position
using the environment Bill even though
it's not mandatory yet and that results
in half a million pounds with off-site
contributions as well to local projects
this is an architecturally LED scheme
and it does adopt good practice of good
The Good the principles the good
principles of good Urban Design and
building better and building beautiful
homes and that's backed up by the urban
designers consultation response to the
application the homes themselves will be
extremely energy efficient offering a 31
reduction in carbon emissions compared
to the 2013 building regulations and
that's done by using PV on every roof
heat recovery systems mechanical
ventilation car charging points to every
property
the development also exceeds your your
affordable housing policies it's
actually 38 affordable housing on on the
26 dwellings and it's tenure blind and
it's spread throughout the site
and excluding the half million pound for
the biodiversity net gain the
development prize provides almost 2
million pounds for Redditch and
Stratford in infrastructure
contributions and that does consist of
NHS foundations NHS ccgs libraries
education public transport and public
transport promotion
um we're obviously pleased at Radix
Borough Council have resolved to approve
most of the developments and thereby the
main principles of uh at their committee
a couple of weeks ago and in doing so we
noted that the officers and the members
there said that the development complied
with all of their adoptive policies and
ticked every box
we believe that the same can be said as
the application that's presented you to
you this evening and we're there for you
with effort ask that you continue the
collaborative Legacy achieved to date in
enabling both the Redditch local plan
and your own site allocation plan to
come forward to to deliver these much
needed sustainable homes as part of
everyone's housing delivery programs and
we ask that you vote in favor of your
office's recommendation for approval
Goodwin thank you very much well within
your time members do we have any
questions for our agent
Council cargo
you've got a couple of it I'll just do
you far away you keep going until I stop
I have a question for you regarding the
um the loss of the the poplars
um and replanting isn't it it's a valid
point made that we will lose the
wildlife during that period of time have
you any mitigation plans in for that
yes we have we employed um fpcr who was
an independent psychologist to not only
assess the ecology that's there at the
moment but also provide the biodiversity
Net game
proposals in order to maximize the
biodiversity going forward so there are
two stagnant ponds on the site which
don't have any wildlife in them at all
and we've got plans to combine those and
turn that into a biodiversity habitat
there's also some new swales some new
ditches and all of those include
biodiversity habitat as well
the upshot of all of that including the
native Woodland that we're putting in
and The Wildflower Meadows and then on
the properties themselves there's the
and I call them the obligatory black
boxes and bird boxes they'll be on there
as well but most of the biodiversity
habitat improvements is what we are
setting aside in the Stratford area and
that's resulted in the biodiversity Net
game position so there's a whole range
of of biodiversity and there will be a
significant Improvement it's not going
to be immediate but it will be there in
the long term thank you on that
particular point if I may
um are you engaging or will you be
engaging with the local schools to
actually promote this within the school
so the children can come and actually
contribute to this
um we we have a we have a long track
record of working with with local
communities throughout developments
um we've had garden design schemes done
we've had Show air designs can we speak
to this particularly well we haven't we
haven't got anything planned at the
moment because we haven't got the
certainty of a planning permission yet
but we will engage with local schools
and with the local communities and with
the local residents to come up with
schemes that they can they can
contribute to
okay thank you okay Council cut is next
please
just a couple of points you mentioned
that there'd be significant
contributions to public transport of
infrastructure under the NHS trusts
um will you be able to get a bus to the
pool Medical Center in suddenly from
this side
I don't know the answer to that I'm
afraid
um
no I don't I do know the the main bus
service is on far more Lane yeah and
there was a threat that that bus service
was going to close but that it's now
been announced that that's going to be
obtained and improved I think we'll ask
our officers okay just to confirm
um Council Mills next please
well then just going back to the
wildlife
um are there things like badgers deer
whatever in the are there at the moment
um we've carried out full extent of
ecological surveys twice now once in
2018 and again in 2020 but don't quote
me on that I can't remember the dates
um it included surveys for greater
crested Utes but any other protective
species
um we didn't find any bat routes
um the local residents say that they've
seen deer in the Woodland
um but but you didn't see any evidence
of deer or Badgers no there were no
badges definitely no badges on the site
okay
that's a hobby please thank you
the number of school places that we will
be demanded as a result of this
development and how that number squares
with the
um available places in local schools
so the section 106 said there's been a
consultation with both County Council
education authorities
um they've assessed the school places
that are available and they provided
um education contributions through the
section 106 in order to provide the
school places that are needed for the
development
that doesn't answer my question
that's his answer councilor Crump
s
um you've mentioned you've got a strong
track record of engaging with local
communities yet we've heard two speakers
tonight said that you weren't able to
speak to them you weren't able to attend
the meeting I think it was on the 2nd of
December
um can you give us some confidence that
you'd be able to engage with local
communities and respect some of their
wishes that if this application was
approved please
uh uh absolutely yeah not forgetting
that this planning application was
submitted at the beginning of the
pandemic we set up a website a dedicated
website for this we sent out to leaflet
drop to all residents and provided them
with email addresses that they could
write to and we also engage with local
Ward councilors and sent them updated
plans as and when they were changing so
there was some Community engagement
there
um the recent invitation to attend the
meeting on the second that was to me and
that was at the parish council meeting
uh for mapleborough green on a week ago
on Friday and I
couldn't attend on this on on that day
because it was my daughter's birthday
basically but we we will engage going
forward we've got a long-standing track
record of local response to local
football teams Etc and I did say to the
members of win Yates that I will happily
attend a meeting to answer questions
when their next meeting is which I
believe is in January
okay thank you Council Rock did I see
your hand go off earlier no in that case
do we have any other questions for our
agent no
Mr Goodman thank you very much for your
time pleasure this evening thank you
okay I've lost my papers there we are um
our next speaker is Concentra Serafin
come on down
now you'll have five minutes and I'm
gonna I'm not gonna give you the extra
10 seconds because you probably don't
need it but uh okay thank you chair just
in the interest of moving forward so
whenever you're ready and set and
comfortable the time is yours okay
um with this uh application of Reserve
sites there's actually been a lack of
Engagement in the beginning and a lack
of transparency
and
when I first objected to this Reserve
site
funny enough I was told it was drawn off
a Google map
and
nothing else was said to me
it's only recently that this has been a
joint application and yet the talks have
been going on for some years
so I find that
not very helpful at all
um
I'm not against house building
I've been a builder all my life
they are the wrong houses in the wrong
place
and if everybody's read the white report
it recommends
that the benefit leaving it as it is
eggwise building
we have lost 50 percent of biodiversity
in this country
that is more than any G7 country
these trees I realize that they are
hybrid populace and their life is
shorter than a lot of trees but they've
been a benefit
they've soaked up carbon
oxygen giving and water retention
and they are actually known
as water Hogs
because they soak up 50 gallons of water
every day
now this is a very wet area
there are a lot of Natural Springs
coming from gawkid Hill which all the
ground flows into it
there are ponds with overflows that
comes into this land
I did look at a borehole a few weeks ago
when I walked into this uh designated
area
and it was full my feet were wet
so it is constantly wet
um as this white report and especially
Dave Nash had said there needs to be a
buffer between settlements and that is
important
and the loss of habitat
in my mind and I've seen these their
idea there are badges
buzzards bats
and everything else you can do with
habitat
um we did have a face-to-face
consultation with Morris Holmes
which has actually taken me a long time
to achieve on the 25th of November
and at this meeting
Gary Goodwin actually said
we don't need these to build these
Stratford houses Morris Holmes actually
said that this big minute
um
I just find
that we are
not taking this biodiversity seriously
enough
what these trees do they have still got
some life in them and I understand
they'll come down eventually
but what is growing up in between these
trees is native saplings I've walked in
these Woods many a Time
and you're talking of supplements of
eight foot to 15 foot maybe taller
when these trees actually come down
you will have a natural Woodland
which would only be good
for the biodiversity and habitat
um
it's also this screening between
settlements
and if the councilors who actually came
out for a site visit the other day
noticed that the Birmingham Road was a
very busy road but that was such a quiet
time you haven't seen it at a busy time
and you take all these trees away you're
losing this carbon capture which is
important
and we as a council adopted the green
climate emergency and we should take
this more serious
motherboard have done a housing survey
they don't need any more houses in
musselburgh
um
what else can I say
I could go on forever but I won't repeat
what has been said because I agree with
what the previous speakers have been
said and I urge committee members to
think seriously
and reject this application
thank you Stephen thank you very much
well within your time members do we have
any questions for our war member please
no oh cancer Dixon thank you
Peter you uh you mentioned the white
report yeah this is a very extensive
degree which I had uh today and uh
I seem to remember in there that that
was submitted prior to the Redditch
local plan and if it was
not overwritten but when the inspector
agreed the Redditch local plan he'd seen
that white report and basically still
gave
permission on the Reddit side of their
boundary for 230 houses or the
development of that land is that right
or am I mistaken on that basically I
think that's right but it did um state
that there needs to be a buffer there
and the buffer really should go down to
the boundary
so so you've got at least 60 meters
where where the
Stratford housing are
there is only a short buffer zone but
with the noise of the traffic and the
pollution that is not enough as a buffer
zone no okay
okay if there are no other questions
which doesn't appear there are concern
surfing thank you very much for your
time your contribution
okay we will move to clarification to
our officers I've got a lot of stuff
written down would you rather I went
through them all or would you like to
have a go first and you can mop can we
go for it right
Louise first of all and we've heard a
lot about trees being cut down how many
have been cut down and uh how many are
being uh delivered
um there are 515
um popular trees being removed together
with 11 native trees however there are
600 new native trees being planted and
also retention of I think it's
approximately 41 existing native trees
which was in the areas of the north east
um near to the where where um the agent
was referring about ponds merging around
that area
okay um so 550 300 600 uh going in we've
used to referred earlier to a felling
license for the site as well so am I
right in thinking that selling license
allows all of those Partners to go
regardless of whether we approved
tonight yes if we remind you to yes so
they could go tomorrow yes okay that's
helpful thank you very much Dave
um we heard about infrastructure I think
Council Curtis asked about um getting a
bus from here to for example studly
uh Sports and Leisure
or Health Center sorry I I must adapted
um what Provisions are there in that
sense from this site to be able to get
to elsewhere most of the services are in
Worcestershire but services are in
Worcestershire we've brought up a bus
map we think the five one two does
actually pick up the bottom
um Southern corner of the site and goes
down towards Studley and then through
studly and out towards Ulster but that's
an irregular service and it does look
like the um 60 62 was it John the 62 bus
you could get the 62 bus down to wash
the belt and then pick up the 247 bus
down there so it would involve the bush
change but there is the possibility of
getting there by public transport so the
facilities are there there just might
not be as convenient as one might want
them to be yeah that's right um okay
thank you very much and far more Lane
I'm unclear exactly where that is uh is
if we could get a map up mine is the
site on the western boundary of the site
which is which is entirely that's in
Redditch I thought you might say that in
that case my next point about that is
moot so it doesn't matter
um John
can you tell me what the status is of
our sap and this
proposal or what the our element of this
proposal uh and how it fits within that
sap please
so the the site allocations plan is the
preferred option stage
um so there's still a further stage
which would be submission so it's it's
still um relatively early on
um that plan seeks to identify a number
of reserved housing sites
um for a number of needs and means
including unmet needs from Birmingham
uh and it's proposed that this site here
would contribute to those um or make a
small contribution to those needs for
birming
and I think uh Louise's in her report uh
affords limited weight to the uh sap
giveness relatively early stages of
preparation okay that's very helpful
that was going to be my next question on
that one um we heard earlier from I
think it was the parish council uh
councilor Barry uh about the double
counting of students and the numbers can
you elaborate on that for me please
yes so this is a an issue
um
that a number of people particularly
around Coventry have
um argued uh they're wrong with the 2014
population projections and the ons has
accepted their there is an issue
particularly with Coventry uh and uh
hence why the new sensor is quite useful
I'm not aware that it's been an issue
with with Birmingham but you could argue
that if it's issue a commentary it
should be a technician with Birmingham
it applies as my understanding to its
higher education so University students
who might live elsewhere
um as opposed to college students who
might sort of live live at home
um
and it's yeah yeah affects the
population projections and assumptions
about how much future housing we will
need uh or burning might need I I think
given the scale of sugar from burning
Birmingham
housing market area
um I I don't I'm not aware that's the
second issue as it is in Coventry
okay so the problem seems to be mainly
in Coventry it could potentially be in
Birmingham but the numbers are so great
that actually if both is actually it's
not going to be material it relates to
understand University students
University students okay that's helpful
thank you um uh and coalescence and
buffers between we've heard about uh
David Nash and the comments he's made
and through the course strategy process
talk to us about that please
well I think the the issue is a changing
context so we we object it to the the
Redditch allocation uh and there were a
number of allocations uh right along the
the corridor between uh Reddit and about
the green and 435 uh we were successful
in in a couple of sites being removed
and the scaling back of this site but we
I suppose we lost the argument and the
inspector accepted that the Redditch
site should be included in their local
plan and it's really that that changing
context
um offers an opportunity to to allow a
more comprehensive approach to if you're
Master planning the sites and that
coupled with feedback biodiversity
things about a small contribution to
unmet needs given we're close to
Redditch which is in firmly in the
Birmingham housing market those things
together
we've promoted uh this small site as
part of the resource sites
in in the site locations plan our view
is that the coalescence can be
preventively built still be some
screening
um but it is obviously a reduction in
what's there at the moment but we think
on balance with all the other benefits
that is an acceptable so the the
ultimately the the buffer the tree
buffer and the ponds and the other great
Green Oak space provides the buffer to
prevent the coalescence of the two is
ultimately is the position you've taken
yes and obviously the where the land
passes for the 26 homes in in strategies
on the map but it does it does narrow
that that buffer
um but we our view is that it's still an
exceptional buffer
um
and coupled with all the other benefits
okay understood thank you very much I
think that actually has exhausted my
list already so has anyone got anything
they want to mop up cancer Rock
ask what options we've actually got here
have we got the option just to refuse it
or Grant it
um because in our bit we've got
the enabling areas the Swale ponds and
stop at the North End and we've got 26
houses at the bottom end
so can we do a a partial approval
whatever it's called
so it's all or nothing so the enabling
bit at the top of the Landscaping
buffers and all that we can't grant that
and then remove houses or anything like
that okay thank you councilor Cargill
please
thank you
um right a couple of questions if I may
first Louise on page 82 we've got the
section 106 monies until allocations Etc
um I'm assuming and please correct me if
I'm wrong those are all to stop the
district council they're not pro-rated
yeah
okay uh yes
um
however with the exception of a bullet
point G where it does identify the
biodiversity contribution that that is
going to be shared both 50 50 with
Redditch councils both to use on local
biodiversity projects and I take it then
that the officer hours
all the same not shared
five times 40. no that is specific to
um Stratford or reddish have their own
as well right thank you um pick up a
couple of points about mate the the
argument was that the schools and health
centers may be full
um I just want to clarify on that
particular point because obviously I
think there's a element in your report
that says that those they've accepted
that there's space and availability is
that correct
uh
[Music]
all right
and why are you looking for that John
Wright to be able to answer the other
one which is the knuckleborough housing
needs survey
um saying that I know more homes that
are needed there's other questions John
can come comment on
yes well I think it has to it's
addressing different needs so you've got
the housing needs survey addressing the
local Parish leads and then you've got
the the site allocations plan addressing
those wider District needs I think
that's the key Point there's uh we
accept there's a a district need for for
us to provide Reserve help and homes to
help address the burning shortfall and
that issue wouldn't be picked up
okay I do accept that and this would
definitely be counted or be very small
against that particular allocation yes
that's that's certainly the proposal in
the significations plan that we would
count these solely towards Birmingham
say when contribute to our Finders
um
in terms of the education
um the infrastructure County
infrastructure group have been consulted
and they didn't request any education
contribution from the Stratford District
side to our upper remembering there's 26
units being brought forward from
Stratford and prob a probably didn't
meet their threshold but B is also
there's the education contribution that
is going to be requested quite a
substantial one from the Worcestershire
side
um going on to about uh well
613
511 for Middle uh school education and
also
um they've gone up to 244 348 powers of
special educational needs and
disabilities so educational needs are
being addressed however because
obviously 210 dwellings are in Redditch
it's been met there thank you on this
one mate um the veteran trees and things
like that are being protected I mean
yeah well okay first of all I will say
it's it's all the coalescence that's the
big problem uh for this if you drive
down that road well going into today
okay then well I would just ask the
question please on the veteran trees how
can they be protected
um if you just refer to the
it's it's already being determined with
respect to that but they they are
protected in their own Park
oh it is one there's a veteran tree
Council Curtis please thank you Louise I
was just wondering just a point of
clarification I think and so in the um
update sheet it says the community
Warwickshire to ccg they've removed
their request but just to confirm that
the south of Warwickshire NHS Foundation
trust that request is still there yes
yeah and I don't know if this is a point
for debate or for clarifications yet but
although there's funding in the 106
towards
education uh do we know if they're
although there may be the funding is
there the capacity to be able to use
that funding to provide that further
education
those further education facilities
I mean would the school places actually
be there even if the funding is
available does that necessarily mean the
place it's not uncommon for that to be
how these things are dealt with um
certainly my experience has been
predominantly that it will be a
financial contribution but as we've just
heard
um the majority if not all of that
contributions in Worcester not in
Warwickshire and therefore we have
little to no control over it
uh Council Foreman please
application what would the impact be on
the Redditch application
it would be enabled to be delivered
okay any further points clarification
before we dive into the debate no who
would like to kick us off in a debate
councilor Dixon please
thank you chairman
when I saw the size of that site when
there was a diagram was shown there Etc
and I could see 200 plus houses on one
side and 26 on the other I was rather
pleased to see that most of the uh you
might call it the Green Space was in our
part
um and from that point of view I think
that whilst the populace will go they
have a limited life there's already a
failing license available to them Etc as
we said earlier they could go tomorrow
it will take a time for the new trees
and the native trees and all the rest
and that green space to properly develop
but I think there's an opportunity here
for enhancement
and I will be supporting officers
recommendation I propose that we Grant
this application marvelous thank you
very much who would like to go next
Council cargo thanks very much indeed as
I mentioned I have walked the side I was
a friend there today and had a look
around
I feel that the plantation is probably
at the end of its life
um I also would disagree somewhat with
cancer
seraphin because when I looked at it yes
there are some
um small shrubs growing underneath but
otherwise it's basically a monoculture
of stingers and um
an ivy and a bit of grass it's not what
I call a biodiverse area so in that
respect I think that what is being
proposed will improve that because of
the more Modern Way of approaching this
and allowing more light into more
development and then obviously the
biodiversity net gain will be an
advantage there so in that respect I
don't I don't have a major problem with
the poplars going down
um the it is the buffer and it is the
coalescence that I have a real problem
with and we we have Greenback for a
reason
and that is to stop the coalescence but
if you drive down that 435 now there are
Factory buildings all the way along it
there's housing all the way down it's it
is literally there right up and the very
first map that Louise showed us that
tiny little bit of white left on there
that was all there is between us and and
registered development at the previous
one the very first map you showed the
the the big scale one look at that that
is the little bit in the middle of there
that white bit and that's that's all
that basically there is so that is a
concern to me how can we therefore
protect that in in the future and that
is the question I would ask and uh
perhaps someone can comment on them
I I I thought I got a seconding from you
there but then you sort of you've thrown
a curveball in are you you're neither
you'll need the seconding or proposing
an alternative
okay first and then no problem Council
Mills please
thanks Miss Jim yes I mean it's just
touching something that Jill was saying
earlier
um the
the radish side has been granted
if we would go to refuse
um as much as I don't like to see any
trees whatever condition I had taken
down
um but if we would refuse this I'm
going to return to the cleaners by the
inspector
um I I I can't see that we
I can't say we can refuse this Mr
chairman so I support the officer's
recommendation on this thank you just
SoundCloud is that a seconding of
council Texas yeah lovely thank you very
much anyone else like to speak before we
go to a vote Council Curtis
thing on the heart into nothing here but
it
just strikes me again but I'm used to
that um
comes from playing the piano All My Life
um it just seems to me that this is
another development where it's housing
LED and the infrastructure whether it's
public transport whether it's schools
whether it's Health Facilities taking
two buses to get to a healthcare that's
a real that's just a concern for me I
think as I say on a hiding for nothing
but it just seems another example of
Housing Development then rather than
let's get the infrastructure in place
and then see if we can put the housing
in future
understood thank you very much um I
don't think we've got anyone else
wanting to speak so
cramps hiding over there councilor Crump
do you come in at this point you're
coming very briefly
um I think there are still flaws in the
in the process
um in this application but I can't see
many benefits um particularly in terms
of sustainable transport walking cycling
and improvements in the footpaths ETC
um which will help us so ease a an
existing problem
um so the the benefits directs outwide
that the negative so I will be
supporting the application
you very much okay so we have a proposal
to Grant in line with the office
recommendation proposed by cancer Dixon
exactly by Council I have a show of
hands for those in favor of granting
seven and against
two
committee therefore resolves to Grant
application
21.00204 ful is land of far more Lane uh
in map of a green
thank you very much indeed now members
we are very quickly getting towards half
past eight which as you know we have to
have started our final item by then and
we have two left and I don't think we're
going to get one done in eight minutes
so I'm going to ask to have a vote now
for us to continue uh to hear the final
two is everyone happy with that
that is unanimous marvelous okay with
that in mind I'm also going to allow a
couple of minutes break so we can have a
quick pit stop right we have been here
for two and a half hours so we will be
back momentarily
sorry uh allow me to bring you to a nice
bit of open Countryside uh death is
break between Depp's bridge and ladbrok
um
just on the parish boundary which you
can see more clearly on this slide runs
along the the line of the stream and
that is the the application site there
are no special landscape designations
listed buildings public rights of way or
or anything else to complicate that
this is the proposal uh it's a
a rural workers dwelling associated with
the equestrian business on the site site
between the
um the equestrian buildings and the road
accessed by the existing access
this is what it will look like uh it's
slightly we have had previous uh
applications for for pretty much this
development 20 in 2017 2019 and 2021
just slightly reduced in scale from from
those attempts uh and it is to replace a
temporary dwelling which was first
authorized in 2014 with an application
submitted in 2013 and then renewed in
2017.
[Music]
uh this is the access and so I'm
conscious here that the ward member in
the applicant are both showing quite a
lot of photographs so I've kept my brief
this is the the access left and right
and this is the site of the dwelling
itself chair there are no objections on
my part uh on matters of detail the
issue is solely one of principle uh the
independent consultant engaged by the
council concludes that the business is
not growing to the extent projected in
the earlier applications that I
mentioned
um to the uh extenders are expected
there and also the extent that's
necessary to ensure the essential
functional need for a permanent
full-time residence on site and the
viability of the Enterprise for the
foreseeable future uh I'd like to draw
your attention also to the update sheet
the applicant has by the agent has
submitted some additional points
regarding Insurance the horses on site
and depreciation of assets and councilor
Kettle as County councilor and the
neighboring Ward member has written in
support with some some additional
comments there chair on the basis of the
principle not being met my recommend is
refused plan Commission well thank you
very much indeed let's call our first
speaker on this item who is the
counselor Copley from ladbook Parish
Council
good evening Council Copley thank you
very much for your patience
and once you're comfortable and settled
you'll have three minutes would you like
me to give you a 30 second warning why
not marvelous I'll do that in that case
whenever you're ready the floor is yours
okay uh good evening I'm here on behalf
of Ladbroke Parish Council in support of
Mrs Buckle bank's planning application
the parish council supports the
application due to the need for the
Royal worker to be available on site 24
7 to support the stud activities and the
benefit of the Enterprise brings in
supporting the Royal economy I've been
asked by my fellow councilors to attend
this evening as I have experienced as a
private breed of quality show jumpers
using Stallions in the UK and Europe and
we have used several studs in the UK
with the planning permission for
temporary dwelling Mr brookbank has
embarked on significant investment to
support the growthly Enterprise from
2014 to 2022 this includes agricultural
building to hay barn stables and Menage
horse walker and a lengthy driveway
however without a permanent resident
residence there is a significant risk to
further growth of the stud activities
and to the associated economic benefit
to Mrs brucklebank the parachute ladbrok
and The Wider area including local feed
suppliers vets barriers dentists Trace
people's Farm farmers and more
whilst Mrs broccoli breeds from her own
group mares providing stud services to
owners of blue mares is a route for
growth of the stud operation those
breeding horses must plan forward
as the period for the mayor to be put in
fold to the fold being weaned is
approximately 18 months
as a result a 24 service by definition
needs a level of certainty regarding the
sustainability of a stud service when
making a decision to board a broodner
this requirement applies also to
delivery services no owner risks their
horse becoming homeless when considering
a livery Arrangement a temporary
dwelling fails to provide this certainty
and limits the attraction of Brock Farm
to potential customers
the financial figures indicate a growth
during the pandemic despite the negative
impact across the UK economy
the growth may not be as planned in 2015
but has achieved has been achieved
despite the economic conditions and the
ongoing uncertainty of a temporary
dwelling an uncertainty which is
difficult to justify considering the
various planning commissions that have
been granted and the last as recently in
2022 to enable further investment in
facilities
refusal Planning Commission for a
permanent dwelling for an Enterprise
which has been established for eight
years risks impacting the growth of the
study at stud and other services yet
growth is the one thing that is being
stipulated as a requirement for
permission for a permanent dwelling
the parish council is not aware of any
requirements being stipulated in this
regard and accept that enterprises
evolve as circumstances dictate 30
seconds Mrs brookelbank finds herself in
a catch-22 in my experience there's a
shortfall of stud facilities both local
and within Warwickshire my Mayors and
young stocks are delivered this files
field as Wiltshire this would suggest
that given the right environment there
is an opportunity for growth bringing
positive impact for the local economy
and the UK equestrian breeding industry
Ladbroke Parish Council has consider
this application shouldn't be granted
spot on your time thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
with our Council please
no
in that case Council thank you very much
for your time contribution this evening
okay let's call on our next speakers who
are our agent and our applicant so we
have a Mr John Clark our agent and Ms
Tracy brusselbank who is our applicant
excuse me now I understand it uh that um
Mr Clark you're going to be speaking for
a minute is that right and then the
commensurate time will be taken by Mrs
Brockbank so do you want me to give you
a 30 second warning or should I tell you
when your minutes up and then we'll hand
over
yes please
I certainly can now I understand we also
have a presentation uh is the
presentation yours supposed to come uh
no it's uh for Mrs brockle bank so when
I finish my minute I'll hand over to Mrs
brockle bank and if the officer can then
put the photos on when she starts to
speak okay um a warning for all of our
viewers and of course people around the
table there are images of a graphic
nature within that presentation
uh generally injuries to animals so just
please be aware of that if you're not
comfortable with it obviously turn away
okay
um did we settle whether I was going to
tell you with your minutes up or are you
just going to speak I will tell you when
he was there so I'll tell you on a
minute and then we'll go thank you when
you're ready to close yours
chairman members this is not an open and
shut case but a matter of judgment on
the essential need for the applicant to
live on site please consider four things
firstly National guidance accepts the
need for a royal worker to live at their
place of work to ensure the effective
operation of a business where animals
need on-site attention
certainly what your Consultants Kernan
say which is it's a matter of judgment
based on factors such as the frequency
of out of ours problems the ability of a
resident worker to identify and address
those problems the severity of loss if
they are not addressed and the potential
for notification of problems to a worker
living off-site
thirdly the granting of Planning
Commission for a mobile home twice
before says the need has already been
accepted
finally all the information provided
over a year and a half including
accounts which confirm the business has
been profitable in each of the past four
years proposals for growing the business
funding details of the house
please don't accept my word on essential
need that is a minute just so you're
aware but the views of the local
community and the applicants who I pass
over to now okay hello I'm Tracy
brockelbank I own the stud and have done
for 16 years my business has two main
parts firstly a commercial stud
producing quality bowls for dressage
show jumping and Eventing and secondly a
livery service the stud is about 25
acres we're stabling for 16 horses an
outdoor Menage horse walker and paddocks
I currently have five brood mares five
folds three of which recently sold four
Youngs four young stock four full-time
liveries two horses and three ponies
I've lived in the mobile home for over
six years the implication for my
business if I can't live on site is that
it wouldn't continue
it is crucial that medicine Falls are
given the highest level of care and that
I am on site 24 7. during 11 months of
pregnancy Mayors require constant
monitoring during falling I have to
check the Mayors throughout the night
sometimes hourly the second slide shows
a mayor that was cast in her stable if I
hadn't been living on site and hurt her
distress I would probably have lost both
mayor and fall I need to be in Sight and
Sound of these horses
the third slide shows examples of
injuries that have to be dealt with
promptly I run a full range of Livery
services including recuperation holiday
and Fuller part Livery clients send
their horses to me from anywhere between
a weekend and several months the Livery
side of my business should not be judged
solely on numbers but on the quality of
service I can offer a local show jumper
sends horses to me when he's abroad
competing for weeks at a time these are
international horses which require care
Around the Clock due to their high value
some in excess of fifty thousand pounds
my business has been cut and continues
to be successful and has made a profit
of nearly twenty thousand in each of the
past four years including throughout the
pandemic should you have any doubts
about what I'm saying please I urge you
to visit as a committee rather than
refusing the application which would be
dealt a death now for my business thank
you
spot on your time again well done thank
you okay
um members uh I'm not sure whether I
should be concerned about how intently
you all looked at the screens knowing
there was graphic numbers but do you
have any questions for either our agent
or our applicant
Council cargo first
um it's where people own horses but
haven't got a place to keep them of
their own so they pay for me to either
look after them or house them and they
come to me and look after them
themselves thank you Council Mills
um how long did you say you've been
living in your mobile home over six
years
uh and how long has the business been
going for
uh about 12 years where did you live
with uh we rented a farmhouse literally
just up the road right okay thank you
Council Crump
um I didn't know the site very well I'll
go past it didn't even save them quite
often so a couple of questions really
um you mentioned it's for the last four
years it's made a profit of twenty
thousand
um
how was it affected by covert the
pandemic and how did your experience in
terms of profitability and customers
compared to national
Trends to do with their profitability
well when travel was restricted I looked
after the Livery horses completely so
they couldn't write like you couldn't
see Nana you couldn't see your horses
either I obviously had to charge them
more because I was doing the soul work
um
and we just managed we just coped I
exercised other people's horses through
lunging them which is putting them on a
long line and letting them run around
the school or on the horse walker
um and during the summer months I put
them into fields and brought them in and
put them out and put them in for
everybody else
and can you explain or let me know how
your business is unique compared to
similar
um staples delivery Etc it's Unique in
the sense that but I offer recuperation
um I've got enough
knowledge to be able to look after
people's horses and to know what I'm
doing when an animal has been injured
and needs looking after
um
in the long term rather than
have it in a lot of times people only
have the room have got it on a grass
delivery say and they need a stable to
put it in but haven't got one where they
are so they use my facilities they use
my horse walker which not everybody's
got
um
and I just offer a unique service of
care
okay thank you very much okay any
further questions members no in that
case you both thank you very much for
your time your patience and
contributions
okay uh we will call our final speaker
on this item is Council Rock
Council Rock You know the drill you'll
have five minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning if you want it I have the
30 seconds Germany if I can of course no
problem and as soon as you're I'd say
I've got the first slide and I'll see
Paul is poised the floor is yours thank
you very much
uh this decision uh hinges on whether
the business is a credible ongoing
concern that can support a rural worker
further what is the reasonable length of
time to demonstrate that the business is
sustainable
our judge of this is not a cynical
device to achieve a dwelling in the open
Countryside
Mrs brocklebank has worked to establish
this business since 2007. latterly
returning a consistent commercial
performance next slide please
any visit to the facilities will show
the determination of the applicant and
her family to make this a success with
the construction of stables horse
Walkers menages folding sheds tap rooms
and all the other paraphernalia needed
on top of this the family believed for
more than six years in a caravan tucked
around the back of the barn to keep the
Enterprise going
living in cramped circumstances and
dealing with both the business and
domestic pressure from there go to the
next slide please
the business simply cannot operate
without on-site living accommodation so
refusing a dwelling will close the
business
as well as the need to be on court to
look after breeding animals customers
will not bring their horses to a stood
and Livery business without someone
being here overnight for welfare reasons
the account show for the last four years
a sustained gross profit of around 30
000 pounds a year and twenty thousand
pounds a year net gained against the
background of the pandemic
if Mrs brocklebank chooses to have a job
she loves but lower pay than the average
which incidentally has been shown to be
more than 25 more than the UK minimum
wage why should the state tell someone
how to live their life under throttle
Enterprise not slide four please
there are three key paragraphs in page
89 of the report
in paragraph four it has been agreed
that the need
has been established paragraph five
implies another period of temporary
accommodation is maybe an alternative
because the Caravan could be removed in
future
this would be kicking the can down the
road
what would happen if the business is
still trading steadily at present levels
do we close it down then
this will deny Mrs brockle Bank both her
home and her business surely this cannot
be right
then in paragraph six the criticism from
the consultant is that the business has
not expanded as was originally projected
in 2015.
the core strategy is-10 paragraph I and
the nppf wording requires functional
need which seems to be uncontested
neither of these policy documents
mandate profit levels or guarantee the
future expansion
just the as10 Note 10 on page 197 if
you've got your book looks for it to be
sustainable
expansion is not the same as
sustainability
given the trading conditions noting what
has happened to all types of businesses
in the wake of the pandemic one local
horse owner said to me she's done well
to keep going at these levels
the British equestrian organization
published a national survey in March
this year on challenges for the
equestrian sector around viability costs
marketing and profitability and the
impact of covid finding an average of 62
reduction of income for riding
establishments since the lockdowns of
2020 and 2021.
turning to other factors next slide
please
there's a there is another Catch-22 here
promoting this business including by
visible signage at the road would have
security implications a better place
dwelling for gatekeeping would help
security and the prospects for business
advertising
top right in this picture 300 meters to
the south in an adjoining field the
council house a few months ago and
correctly allowed this prominent bomb to
support a rural business I accept the
comparisons are technically difficult
different but not much so
a refusal it would appear would be based
on the consultant's view of past custom
and practice not what is actually
written in our adoptive policy wording
how would that look to an inspector
in summary the application for a raw raw
workers dwelling has met the functional
need test in the mppf and the
requirements of as10 paragraph I
by showing continuing and consistent
income level for a number of years
through the pandemic it has met
sustainability test in the note 30
seconds effectively extinguishing the
business would be contrary to the aims
and Clauses in is-10 for business and
tourism on page 193 of the book
I can't see a planning harm of a
dwelling in this location on the
landscape or as an adverse precedent the
application should be granted
Council Rock thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for
Council Rock please Council crumb
um
are you
you say that you're in disagreement with
um the consultant's report because it
didn't take into account sufficiently
the effects of the pandemic on the
business
um
I would need to read through the report
to see precisely what it said on that so
um
uh I I I I don't I it would be truthful
to say I don't know the answer to that
extent
um I I I've got it in front of me but
I'm sure the committee doesn't want me
to sit here and read it what I'm
suggesting we should take into account
the effect of the pandemic
together with many other considerations
that I've outlined thank you thank you
if there's any other questions for
councilor Rock
no thanks Rob thank you very much for
the contribution
okay let's move to points clarification
with our officers who would like to ask
any questions Council Dixon please
four
if we have minded to Grant this
application
it's an equestrian dwelling called
workers dwelling is that the same as an
agricultural would it have an
agricultural tie to it or something of
equivalent strength yes there would be a
condition tying it to the business
operating on site so it would it would
come as a parcel with that thank you
any other points of clarification
note those moment is about who would
like to kick us off
for the first time everyone wants to fly
me
Council Redding was first so I'll go
Council Redden first please
have him I say tonight are they yeah
um yeah that's my only Point
um
to me it looks very much like you know
it's an established business it's
settled we're being told on one hand
that it's
not viable but by the owner that it is
it's making a profit that's a viable
business as far as I'm concerned
uh the need for the residents seems
proven to me
to my mind
um
and the need also established due to the
granting of the Caravan on site and
there seems to be lots of public support
to my mind I'd be quite happy to propose
that we actually Grant on this one okay
I'm gonna assume that is an actual
proposal
perfect thank you very much we'll come
back to you for some reasoning in a
minute councilor Cargill please thanks
very much indeed I think this is one of
those situations where we get the the
cold analytical report from an
accountant on the other side we get the
passion of somebody who's obviously in
love with her business and the animals
which I will say is and horses have two
dangerous ends and I know this
um my personal view is that we should
Grant this it's not up to us necessary
to say it's is it a viable business it's
it it's up to that person there we
should be supporting rural businesses
especially at this moment
we need more uh Agricultural and and
after the pandemic it's been devastating
for us so I think we should be
supporting those and I'm happy to Second
the the
Council
um here so yeah sorry
beautifully but
um councilor Crum next please
it's got the point so I will agree and
disagree with against the cargo firstly
is the next accountant yeah I'm sure
we can show some passion here it might
be slightly limited but we can show some
person but seriously
um
I know the area well I go past it quite
regularly there is a massive Barn that
was built in the next field that's
really prominent and it will support in
a local business I think we've got a
duty to support local businesses
um and to highlight the passion the show
a lot of the applicant who again when
questioned demonstrated that and
demonstrated that she was providing a
unique service that enabled her to keep
the business going through the pandemic
which I think shows some Merit I think
there's a possibility that having the
site and having the the building there
will be able to expand by having better
security on side and then again
potentially advertising as well so again
I think there's possibilities to improve
the turnover
um certainly there's been consistent and
continued growth over the last few years
and has been profitable so I will
support the application
um as part of as councilor Rock said the
Ender will be a page 193 uh is-10 so
hopefully that would be my support of
this application
thank you very much Council Harvey next
please
um
I'm totally comfortable most businesses
if they're going to fail fail within the
first two or three years the fact that
this business has been going for 12
years particularly through a pandemic
take my hat off to the young lady
um
I'm also aware that we have in the past
had applications not dissimilar from
this I can recall one of um a property
wanted on security grounds for a grain
drying statement where the report from
the expert was don't do it refuse it and
Common Sense prevailed and the committee
agreed it and I think the committee
should use some common sense and approve
this as well thank you very much Council
Mills next please
it has all been said Mr chairman yes we
do need to support rural businesses but
of course
um horses are expensive animals and and
for security reasons we do need someone
on site 24 7 so yes I'm supporting the
officers sorry don't support the
officer's recommendation
the granted applications that are
looking at this list we've the girls
have been granting these applications
encouraging the business to grow and I
think it would seem to be wholly
consistent to then Grant this
application further to the naval lab
perfect thank you very much
um
okay so it's just I'm disappointed that
nobody said that profits have been quite
stable over the last four years
I shouldn't let him speak sure
and someone take his microphone away
um okay so we have approach Grant it has
been seconded now I need to just get to
be very clear on a few things
um the reason you're going against the
office of recommendation I think what
you said was that uh notwithstanding the
financial viability report of the
currents report the evidence that you've
seen today clearly demonstrates a need
for someone to be on site for a rural
dwelling or sorry for an equestrian uh
dwelling to be on sale worker Beyond
site at all times uh is that correct
and is there anything else you want to
add to it only that the evidence that
I've seen and heard tonight also
demonstrates sort of came to that report
in terms of there's a business that's
been there for a long time it's making a
profit so I think it's cs22 supporting
rural businesses I think that's right so
well there's two reasons okay so the
next thing we need to worry about are
conditions you've already mentioned the
tie which I think we'll have to have
regardless so we've got that tie
standard conditions are there any
anything that you specifically want to
see in before I get the officers to reel
off their list only the tie that was the
only one anyone else got anything that
they're thinking of no Paul Standard
time limit uh pre-planned condition hard
Landscaping
standard water but recycling bins
rubbish bins parking and turning areas
being laid out and surfaced a broadband
connection uh occupancy restriction as
we've discussed and compliance with the
submitted climate change checklist
marvelous everyone happy
good let's move to a vote so the
proposal is to grant for the reasons
given with the conditions we've just
heard could I have a show of hands flows
in favor please
that is unanimous committee therefore
resolves to Grant application
2201427 fuel Brock Farm stud in adepas
Bridge very nearly got that wrong
okay let's very quickly move on to our
final item of the evening which is
application reference 2202 617 ful the
cottage in Ascot
um our presenting officer will be Louise
Coleman Louise as soon as you are set
ready to go the floor is yours
foreign
[Music]
thank you chair
um the application site identified by
the black dot on the map is located in
the village of alskirt
sorry it's paused
oh
a little bit zoomed in but there we go
um the site is identified by the red
line on the plan is and is located in
the old skirt Conservation area which is
identified by the pink line on the map
also it's within the Cotswolds aom B the
property is also identified as a
non-designated Heritage asset public
rights of way you can see
um but the southern boundary of the site
identified by the green hatched line and
also you can see we want the north
um
The Proposal is
um for full planning application for the
erection of a single story extension
with internal alterations to allow for
single level living accommodation into
the property known as The Cottage the
property is a semi-detached Stone
dwelling and the adjoining neighbors
property is known as holly tree Cottage
so apologies is a delay
as I just do this
there we go
um I'm sorry this is a floor plan of the
existing dwelling
the neighboring property is here
these are the existing elevations so
this is the front of the property no
alterations are proposed here with the
adjoining neighbor
this is the side elevation
so this is what you can see for when the
public footpath that I referred to
um
to the south of the site
this is looking at the rear
of the proposed the application site and
also this is the adjoining neighbor
hollow tree Cottage so this is their
rear elevation
and this is looking at the northern
elevation
oops apologies and this is the proposal
so firstly if we look at the floor plan
here
see previously it was squared off it's
proposed to be offset from the adjoining
neighbors boundary by 1.7 meters
and this is the area of the extension
going here
so how this translates onto the rear
elevation
so if we remind ourselves this is holly
tree Cottage
this is the area of the extension so
single story set one and 1.7 meters off
the boundary measuring uh 3.9 meters to
the ridge this is looking at the view so
um from the start looking back from the
south from the so where the public
footpath could potentially be a bit
there is screening
um and then this is looking from the
adjoining neighbors elevation so this is
holly tree Cottage
so points to note is that there are two
existing Windows
um serving a room
which belongs to Holly Tree cottages and
it leaves a kitchen Diner area this is
an area here where they have a window
and door
um I'll show you the elevations of that
momentarily you'll note the 45 sorry 25
degree test identified on the plans here
if you look in the report
um so from the kitchen window here there
isn't any conservation controversial
controversial I can't say the word
contravention of the 25 or 45 degree
assessment however from the door here
there's a paneled window
here and there there is a minor
contravention of the 20 sorry a 45
degree assessment
but not the 25.
so this is looking at the property now
so this is looking
um from this from the south at the
existing
um side of the property this is the
boundary
with the neighbor so this is uh shifting
ourselves around a little bit this is
the neighboring property here boundary
line
now I'm standing in the garden of holly
tree cottage which wraps around the back
of the property application site known
as The Cottage so this is the Cottages
boundary line so you can see some sort
of hedgerows and shrubs along here
um this is the close uh boarded panel
fence
you can see parts of the holly tree
Cottage patio
and this is looking from within holly
tree Cottage so again the kitchen
windows which are referred to this is
the uh the paneled door with
um four pin Windows here
and the extension effectively would be
um as I say 1.7 meters off the boundary
there
and this is a view from the footpath
from the south of the site
so the extension is in this area here
and then finally this is a view again
from the adjoining neighbor looking
um so some of their existing windows in
the side elevation and also so you can
gauge the their garden and some of the
existing planting which is within their
property
um the there is one update to report
which proposes an additional condition
requiring details of feral water
drainage to be submitted and the
recommendation is to Grant Subject to
the additional condition uh conditions
listed in the report and notes as
detailed in the premature report
Louise thank you very much indeed we'll
call our first speaker on this item is
councilor Mark burstell of warmington
and ask it Parish Council
good evening
thank you very much for your patience um
you've seen us before you know the drill
three minutes do you want your 30 second
warning
probably yes please I'll give you a 30
second morning whenever you're ready the
floor's yours
good evening
the cottage lies in the center of the
Ascot Conservation Area
is one of a pair of identical estate
Cottages built in the early 1800s
they're called out specifically in the
Isles Conservation Area document which
states the answer Cottages are of
sufficient interest to Merit listing
these two Cottages occupy a very
prominent position on the Village Green
I have to say
I'm slightly surprised at the
conservation officer hasn't submitted a
report
or commented on this
the proposed extension now before you
would change
something that has existed for years in
spite of significant alterations to both
properties they've each retained the
original footprint of the house and the
art buildings
you saw earlier that there is going to
be now something extending significantly
to the East and the South and that will
destroy that symmetry
and I believe on that ground alone you
should reject this application
the applicant claims the changes are
needed to enable single-floor living
even if that were true
the extension is not necessary to
achieve the AIM
it only needs a bed to be placed in the
front room for that one of the bathrooms
is already on the ground floor
the cottage is currently a four bedroom
three bathroom property used as a second
house
the current proposal would increase this
to five bedrooms putting yet more strain
on the drainage system
and also written submission has gone
into some detail about that issue
two independent surveys of the existing
septic tank have condemned it has been
too small to serve the property no
longer functioning adequately to treat
sewage with no adequate soak away and
being in a dangerous physical condition
likely to collapse
the environment agency agreed with these
findings and issued the applicant with a
12-month binding notice dated August
2021 requiring compliance with the 2020
General binding rules
that notice has been ignored
now we have a specific interest as a
parish council because the Outfield pipe
from this septic tank discharges into a
ditch which we earn and have
responsibility for
War extra flood defense has declared the
ditch to be a Watercourse
in summer in particular the stench from
the septic tank is extremely unpleasant
so I'm delighted to see the updated
information about condition
cancers I believe you've got the power
to help us to resolve part of this issue
I hope you will decide to refuse the
application on the grounds that I set
out in the beginning
if you do then please list as one of
your reasons for refusal the inadequate
file drainage provision
let's get this put on the record clearly
if you decide to Grant the application
which I hope you won't then I would ask
that a condition be placed on it that
prevents any work being undertaken until
such time as an acceptable compliant
biodontist system has been installed
thank you for your attention I'll be
happy to clarify any questions you may
have thank you very much I was so
absorbed in what you're saying I forgot
to give you your 30 second warning and
you didn't go marginally over so I'm
sorry for that I am going to have to
give a few extra seconds to other people
members do we have any questions please
councilor Dixon
um you mentioned that these are two
original Cottages as such
from the green looking at the frontal
view there I can see there's probably no
changes have there been no changes to
either property since they were first
built
uh from the green no from the face from
the front elevation no but from the rest
yes yes thank you
any other questions members cancer cover
you mentioned the
um original footprint can you just
elaborate on that because obviously you
we we're seeing from the pictures that
there has been an extensions at the rear
of the property there have been
extensions that they have retained the
original footprint of
the two Cottages the the outbuildings
that were at the back so they've been
built over that footprint on both sides
okay councilor Harvey can you just be
absolutely sure that this property is
not a listed building it isn't listed
thank you they said it was it might
weren't distinct that's why I asked okay
I don't think there are any more
questions no council vessels thank you
very much for your time contribution and
your patience
okay let's call for our next speaker who
is Mr Duncan Chadwick on behalf of the
neighbors
uh Mr Chadwick I'm going to assume
you've had a pretty good idea of how
things are going to work you'll have
three minutes if you want the 30 second
warning I'll give it to you if you don't
want it let me know now I'll take the 30
second more I'll give you a 30 second
warning um otherwise whenever you're
ready you're gonna get three minutes and
five seconds
over here good evening committee members
uh Mr Mrs hatwell have asked me to read
out their statement the disappointed
they can't be here but they are working
overseas
so um and they can attend and it wasn't
possible to have remote participation
so they say our whole majority is the
cottage the only semi-detached
properties in ascot
councilor burstell has already explained
that the history and the background to
the extensions
the committee report suggests the
proposals will result in a more balanced
appearance but we feel strongly that the
4.6 meter or 15 foot projection will
result in most unbalanced appearance
with the extension protruding Beyond
holly tree Cottages you can see on the
screens removing the current symmetry at
the rear
as you know your policies as10 cs9 cs20
you've also got supplementary planning
guidance
all seek to prevent any detrimental
impact upon neighboring properties
however there are three significant and
harmful impacts in this particular case
the first one is loss of sunlight
the committee report acknowledges there
will be a lot of sunlight into my
client's home
for them this is hugely significant
holly tree Cottage the north facing of
the two cottages
and their window and door to the East
are critical sources of sunlight and
warmth into their kitchen area
the other windows in this space are all
North facing the property is already
dark making any loss one of the very
great significance and harm
second concern is orientation and height
the orientation extension is due south
of holly tree cottage which will make
the loss of light even more significant
and damaging to their ground floor
kitchen and dining patio
the committee report says the scalar
proposed projection has been reduced
however we argue as shown in our cgis
which we couldn't display but the height
of this submission has already used at
all
the ridge height is 3.9 meters that's
more than double the height of the fence
at 1.8 meters and in line with their
bedroom window at first floor level
the committee report also misses the
point about loss of light and
overshadowing to the kitchen patio
this is not about God's base this is
about direct impact on their permanent
outdoor dining space immediately joining
their kitchen which is used daily for
every meal in warm weather
this gives them a very important light
and warmth and otherwise dark
predominantly north-facing Cottage 30
seconds
they say this is our family home that
they've cherished for 12 years they
asked the committee few members to
accept that the extension is one of a
semi-detached pair of cottages which
should not be the detriment of the other
and their residential immunity
they consider and we consider the
proposed proposal is insensitive and
harmful to the immunity of their home
we strongly object and who's the
committee to refuse the application
thank you for listening
perfect Simon thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions from Mr
Chadwick please
no in that case Mr Chavez thank you very
much contribution
okay let's call our agent and our
applicant now please our agent Mr Brian
Russell and we have our applicant Mr
David Barnes if you'd like to make your
way forward
good evening to you both and thank you
very much for your patience this evening
now as I understand that Mr Russell
you're going to be doing all the
speaking um and Mr Barnes is here for
questions should he be required is that
right correct marvelous you'll have six
minutes do you want your 30 second
warning yes please okay in that I'm
going to give you actually Gonna Give
You 6 10 because I've given five seconds
extra to other people so commencement
amount of time whenever you're ready
close yours okay good evening
um I don't wish to repeat any much of
what the funding officer is he's done I
just wanted to point out a few points
but we feel they're inaccurate
Mr Barnes has actually lived at this
property for 25 years he's been on the
Electoral roll for all of that time
it's been pointed out earlier by the
chair of the parish council
for whatever reason personal reason or
otherwise
that these questions is Health he's
questioned how long he's lived there
he's actually owned the property for 30
years for the first five years he lived
in London and worked in London and let
it out the holiday let but for the last
25 years he's lived there he's been on
the Electoral roll
we also wish to put it down it's a
three-bedroom house
nobody's questioned the survey this
planning officer has been there he's
viewed it he's content with that
representatives of holly tree Cottage Mr
chadrick Etc have said claimed about
shading and Light
we don't believe that's the case that
the actual building is put back by 1.7
meters away when the planning officer
was there the sun was high in the sky
the one area that provides shading to
their Garden is the two-story section of
their own home
which was approved by appeal
so if you were to look at the drawing
and you look at the elevations
the bottom one there you've got is the
north elevation
and the section slightly in the Middle
with the Dormer the left-hand side
Dormer that is the area that provider
shading which we believe
the building that my practice is
designed is set 1.7 meters back
deliberately with a low ease so that it
actually sweeps away from it so light
can come in all the time and that was
seen by the plane officer
it was witnessed by him the fence there
is 1.7 meters
under permitted development I understand
it could be lifted to two meters if we
wanted to but we don't wish to do it so
the other thing we wanted to point out
was that the proposal retains all the
existing boundaries
everything that is there all the trees
or the foliage
there's a new fence being put up by the
owner on the East Elevation
which my client quite nice it's quite
attractive but everything is there
foliage nothing's changing
so the building is proposed to be
natural stone clay plane tiles dress
Stones around windows to match exactly
what we have elsewhere
but you're not going to see much of that
but what we have done and designed
deliberately on that North elevation the
bottom one again you'll see that the
roof steps down
form was changed when planning consent
was granted by appeal so the actual
shape of the house and the buildings The
Cottages has already changed
we kept deliberately we kept the view
from the green the same when you drive
round you're really going to start the
majority of that elevation on is going
to be behind a fence anyway it's set
back to the shade is not an issue
drainage has been a point of issue
Mr Barnes has had an easement for all of
his time he's had there and and rights
to use the septic tank and Associated
pipe work there have been neighbor
issues about access changing things or
whatever but it has been agreed but that
has to change we have to have a
treatment plan and that's what we've
agreed to that we've been just
discussing with the environment agency
and we're drainage specialist graph UK
and a design has been agreed with them
we've submitted that by understanding
for technical reasons it cannot be
considered as part of the application
but Thanos has that he's asked me it was
beat out with his condition which we
fully support
so we seek your support
oh just before I move on
Mr Barnes the whole purpose of this was
for his long-term
living at his home as I say twice before
he's been there for 25 years
we all wish to let's stay in our own
home as long as we can not just a little
bed in the corner a little couch
otherwise I just designed a two-story
extension possibly but then that would
have put them into definite shade
so that really wouldn't be any
beneficial so we've sought to find a
balance and Design
a very modest extension in size of which
we're grateful to have the planning
officer support
thank you for your time
marvelous thank you very much as well
within your time members do we have any
questions for our agent or our applicant
councilor Cargill please
comment on the um what was suggested
earlier on that the extension does not
fit within the original footprint of the
uh the building the outbuildings
included and is it relevant
I don't believe it's relevant because
the forms already changed so we tried to
follow the design guide well you have
followed a design guide for the step to
roof approach which is where we follow
regularly for when we're doing
agricultural listed building design
which we do commonly so we followed that
approach but we didn't wish to extend to
the South because even though Mr Barnes
keeps his garden is completely treed
over it's beautiful we did but if that
was to ever be flattened you would see
it from the group and we didn't not put
them up so what options we have left so
the option was what we opted for here
okay I don't think there are any other
questions no in that case gentlemen
thank you very much for your time
contribution this evening thank you
okay we'll call our final speaker of the
night who is Council Fielding
and Council feilding you know the drill
you'll have five minutes I will give you
a 30 second warning use as much or as
little as that time as you wish whenever
you're comfortable we will get the
slides up
um and there's another one I think
that's a better one that I asked for
so it shows
John you we've we've got a list of
slides here do you want are we going
through each of them and are you okay
we'll put the slides out for now you're
gonna give us a nod when you want them
changed yeah yeah brilliant times yours
when you're ready
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
I will make a start and if the pick if
the image can come off I would be
grateful
ask it as an attractive Hamlet being
part of the Parish of warmington
the property lies within the
conservation area of Ascot and to the
south of the Cotswold aonb
the ham the cabinet
the Hamlet can be seen from Camp Lane
which runs along the edge of the
escarvement of the aonb
there's a lay-by from which visitors can
look down onto the Hamlet
the cottage and holly tree Cottage are
attached and from Camp Lane you can see
that their footprint matches
cs11 and CS5 landscape state that the
design must have regard to the local
distinctiveness and historical character
of the landscape and the visual impact
of the
um impact of CS5
although
the officers refer to CS6 as there's
little to affect the diversity of the
aonb except for the septic tank that is
polluting the Hamlet's ditch
the officer refers to the overbearing
nature of the extension I agree this is
preferable to what was designed
previously in the previous application
and subsequently withdrawn however
aonb
rises above the Hamlet and lies to the
south of the property the hill casts a
natural Shadow over the Hamlet
that as a two Cottage are tucked under
the OMB holly tree Cottage will lose
more natural light from the extension I
do not understand why the applicant
wants a pitch roof over his extension
the previous application was withdrawn
due to obscuring light from the
neighboring over the neighboring
property
the planning consultant refers to the
45-25 rule which I'm happy to grip to
agree with
in summary not only is the extension
overbearing to the neighboring property
by affecting natural light it also
upsets a symmetry of the footprint of
both holly tree and the cottage
this will be particularly visible from
Camp Lane at the top of the Aon beam we
must maintain the footprints of cottages
I asked that this application be refused
on the grounds of cs11 and 5. and also
cs8 as the cottage is within the
conservation area and the design
Cemetery of cs9 are an important part of
the beauty of these Villages and hamlets
around the Aon mean
Louise the last picture you showed when
you were giving your
report which shows the shade that is
affecting the the property
I would be very grateful that gives some
idea of the problems affected by the
shade
the
applicant
lives on and off in the village as the
councilor um
burstell said and therefore why does he
need to have such a large extension
why does
the last photographer
please
that that gives you an idea of the shade
that was you did give you of the shade
but this is the problem is that that
building that extension will shade over
the patio even
as you can see now how little sunlight
is getting down onto the patio it is the
because of the Aon B is so high in
relation to the cottage every means must
be made allowed for to allow the cottage
to get as much sunlight as possible
therefore such an extension is going to
make it even worse
I rest my case
cancer Fielding
um while you're the gardeners we're
looking at now is that south facing or
North racing sorry is that Garden south
facing or North facing the garden of the
of holly tree is North facing the garden
of the cottage is south facing Marcus
thank you it goes up towards the aonb
thank you members any other questions uh
cancer Dixon was first
uh
Casper Fielding you mentioned that this
was highly visible from Camp Lake there
were some two photographs up there one I
would describe was a winter scene
which I think is probably taken from
your campaign with a view down onto the
Hamlet and the other one included the
zoomed picture which showed the property
more clearly which is a bit like using a
pair of binoculars
um so to I would
do you still assert that campaign
and the property is easily visible from
Camp lake with the naked eye I painted
before I was a district councilor I
painted a picture of the view down which
was bought by the gentleman who lives in
the
um the main house in Ascot because it
showed the cemetery of the Cottages Etc
so that is the visibility that you can
see from that area thank you thank you
Council cargo Mr Speaker you mentioned
about why would they have a pitched roof
sorry you mentioned why would they have
a pitched roof yeah are you suggesting
that a flat roof would be more
acceptable
that's up to the African but I would
hate to lose the footprint yes it might
well be because it doesn't affect the
light but why does he need such a large
extension to a adequate house which has
enough bedrooms Etc
cancel Rock
my question is similar to elaborate on
the question the chairman announced on
on that view that was up a moment ago
the garden faces North yes so the only
time the sun comes onto that patio is
presumably in the morning and and the
afternoon as it goes it won't be
affected by this extension will it
towards evening of course it weren't big
because but in the morning oh morning
yes it is arguable it would affect it
then yeah note in the position of the
fence they need as much light there as
possible okay thank you and light is an
important part I understand okay have we
got any more questions for cancer
feeling please no council building thank
you very much your time contribution
this evening
okay do we have any points clarification
for our officers members okay councilor
Harvey then can I take you to page 100
and the heading impact on Heritage
assets
we've heard that this is not a listed
building
the report doesn't doesn't claim that
it's a listed building
in 66 of the 1990 Act only refers to
listed buildings
but could the officers explain first
why this paragraph is in in relation to
this application
could they confirm that it should be a
standard clause
in any app in any report on any
application that deals with a listed
building because it makes an important
point
uh it doesn't need like an important
point it applies to both listed
buildings and conservation areas as well
though
and although this isn't a listed
building it is within a Conservation
Area
that's a good answer
but it's not clear from what's written
that the reason for its inclusion is
because of the grounds of conservation
it's their last the last word dimensions
of listed buildings that's the suggested
reason for its relevance in the in
what's written note it it could be
clearer and we'll take that away but I
take my
in my view
if you think this is important enough
because it's in a conservation area to
make that point
I think my personal view is that in
relation to any application to deal with
a listed building the same words should
be used because we
say providing special regard I don't it
don't disagree with what you're saying
but obviously we're not going to start
changing reports during a planning
committee meeting I would like an
assurance from the officer that the
point is taken and will be acted upon
understood yes thank you
okay um Council Curtis was next thank
you
um I want to do your thing help there's
been quite a number of mentions of the
current symmetry at the rear of these
two Cottages being maintained
but from the slides that you've shown us
and unless I'm missing something there
appears to be no symmetry at the rear of
these two buildings at all
this is the existing ground floor plan
so this is the application site and this
is the adjoining neighbor
have you got some some of the other
views I I can't see that the rear of the
two buildings
is in any way symmetrical
yeah there are some photos yeah
perhaps you could well first of all if
you can pause there go back on
I guess here because I suppose my point
I'm making is that if one of the
objections is that it destroys the
existing symmetry I think I don't think
this is necessarily a point of
clarification I think this is a debate
okay fine so hold that yeah and we'll
we'll come back to Council Rock please
what's that the uh the sewage discharge
uh and it would appear we that's not a
planning matter yeah and the
environmental health officer has asked
for
uh says the drainage must be
recognized let's say and there must be a
note on there
can can we include make sure if we if we
were minded to approve it can we include
an appropriate condition or a note that
says what the environmental health
officer requires we recommended a
tradition through the update sheets for
a oh I'm sorry
I I take my dressing down
thank you very much okay have we got any
more questions or points of
clarification from officers no let's
move into debate who'd like to kick us
off counselor Curtis
thank you
um yes I'm just as I said there seems to
be quite a few comments made that this
application would destroy
um the current symmetry at the rear of
the buildings but to me that seems a bit
of a red herring because from what I've
seen there is very little symmetry
existing at most I don't think that's a
valid objection
okay thank you very much anyone else
want to contribute in the debate
cancer melts yeah yes thanks Michelle
yes I'm concerned this is is in the
conservation area and
to my mind it does alter the symmetry of
the these two
um although you can't see it in front of
the street so you know I think of it a
thousand water the street scene but um
there's big confused on this one Mr
chairman okay councilor Dixon
uh I would disagree from Council meals I
don't think it is impacted by the street
scene from the front and I think the
amount of vegetation around there is
sufficiently uh enclosing the projected
uh extension and I will support the
officer's recommendation and I will
propose it is granted marvelous thank
you very much I'll second that councilor
Curtis so I've taken that but I would
like to see some conditions over the
septic tank or that connection that has
been contained within the update sheet
have a quick look and see if you're
happy with it Council cargo did your
hand go up no anyone else want to speak
now we have a proposal to Grant in line
with the office recommendation including
the additional condition on the update
sheet could I please have a show of
hands for those in favor of planting
10 10 and those against
one committee therefore resolves to
Grant application oh
2202 617 ful the cottage in ask it I
don't believe there's any urgent but
hang on chaps ladies I don't believe
there's any urgent business in that case
it remains so thank you all thank our
officers and wish you a very merry
Christmas we will see you next year
she says oh no we've got another one we
have got another one
meetings closed